two hello everybody happy
Friday it is December
1st and there's one thing I want to say
is that last night we let the rler talk
even wased up by baby gr he said that
was so
and even and I should speed hitting the
gritty
a grim Shing
fornite a grim is shaking
fornite there's usually yeah there Zach
uh Zach isn't here
today but we have a special filling that
would be
[Applause]
Olivia mute mute mute M she's muted hey
I'm looking for the Applause right now
don't mind me oh yeah you're good you're
good I'll wait for it I'll wait for
Applause you know I think I actually
have one here here oh oh there you go
that one's too enthusiastic there's a
dude who's like
yeah how's that that's good makes me
feel yeah that's a supported
to
um thank you to Shopify for sponsoring
us today imagine that imagine
that imine I'm imagining also shout out
to
chickens
uh greats the birds CH I mean yeah the
birds cuz they they do eggs they lay
eggs that's eggs yeah what yes it is
eggs doesn't it look like
egg last night okay so here we go we got
all kinds of fun stuff everybody's
talking about their Shopify R Spotify R
I can't get Shopify
love it Spotify rap M and we're going to
be playing a little game today where me
and Ela are going to try to guess oh
whose rap list is who and also we'll be
exposing ourselves
too uh we both have YouTube music right
not Spotify and I found out they have a
rap too so that was nice
MH I was almost happy that we could get
away with not having it but they do have
I've never done it before this is my
first time me too were any surprises in
your list um yeah but I'm not going to
tell you so we look at it okay so
yes um that's going to be fun we've got
the let me see here we got all kinds of
good stuff oh dude okay so I just
started watching this on my way to work
Matt r on Jordan Peterson is so
funny dude oh oh my God he go catch
that's who who it was in that thumbnail
Matt R is doing a podcast on Jordan
Peterson show about being cancelled
would do it again go dude quickest
pipeline jump ever no no and Jordan's
like glazing him up so absurdly he goes
he's Brave the bravest young comedian
out there they tried to cancel him and
he told him to go buy a special needs
helmet yeah he's Brave and
fearless and very funny I said so um I
want to watch that up oh yeah you know
so I want to watch that I I think that
that is actually that the thumbnail says
when humor goes too far with Matt
re
yeah damn but uh there's one moment
around four minutes where they say I was
just listening to it and Matt goes you
know if you want to be a real comedian
you have to let the intrusive thoughts
win and I like that has not worked for
me that historically has been an
absolute disaster for me every pretty
much every time you know so no and by
the way it's your friends over at the
daily wire are the ones to with
me so suck it Jordan you you
loser
hypocrite
um two friends online said Ethan's been
real quiet since we dropped our song
Kids Bop on Monday is that is that the
guys oh that is the guys who sounded
like kig Bops oh
really two friends
online shout out shout out also we got
Big Nick
updates which is going to be fun you
know it's always a good time apparently
he's got really wild he's people are
puking and casting out
demons
really so that and so much more wait my
favorite thing that I've been waiting to
watch today is the Elon Musk
interview we're doing that right yeah
yeah so we need that's another thing I
mean golly Elon Musk did this I'm sorry
that takes over big Nick for me I've
been waiting to watch that okay all week
so we're gonna this is going to be an
interesting episode because we're going
to be doing some long form reactions one
is this Elon Musk um interview with the
New York Times journalist and I promise
you I'm not exaggerating when I say it's
the most uncomfortable thing I've ever
watched in my life it painful isn't it
like an hour and a half I'm there's no
way we watch the whole thing I want to
watch the whole thing if I'll go as long
as it's good you know as long as we're
having fun okay I'll I'll keep watching
but I can't imagine that it would stay
fun very long oh you you uh thank you AB
you you timestamped it for me perfectly
oh so you're going to be not funny in
about 15 seconds so you have to let the
intrusive thoughts win in comedy you
have to what what comes if you're a
naturally funny person the first thing
that comes to your mind should be the
funniest thing to you most of the time
Comm I feel like not in this household I
I do I I even like um me having
empirical evidence of that being not
true and being canceled not by the left
but also the right I would say that I
don't believe that that is actually a
good statement I do believe that people
have to
filter uh a bit to get to the good part
of it and to get rid of the bad part you
know right we like filters you know we
love filters don't we
Jordan I think that's where he called
him Brave and courageous though let me
see exactly think through what you're
going to say right I mean if something
strikes you as amusing you pretty much
have to go for it and if your if your
head's full of censorship related
thoughts you're going to be not funny in
about 15 seconds so you have to let the
intrusive thoughts win in comedy you
have to what all right there it is we
watch that it's good
I have that if you want you have what
where he calls him Brave yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah he calls him Brave I love
that he's there's no there's no braver
job than being a stand-up comedian
frankly stand-up
comedians are truly the spearhead of
society yeah as we Advanced as a people
it's the standup comedians that lead the
pack that that are at the Vanguard mhm
they are the bravest soldiers that we
have campaign recent weeks and so we had
a chance to discuss that to discuss his
witty fast Brave and uh appropriate
response to that cancellation to talk
about that sort of thing in more detail
and also to detail out um his I love
that these guys are so they go he just
did a dick he was just being a dick and
then Jordan's like that was so brave and
courageous of you to be a
dick okay buddy well we'll watch that
though I'm going to get ahead of myself
here here yeah but first at the top I
got to give a few shout outs first um we
have I guess the the cards the H3 uh
trading cards that everybody's been
buzzing about the last day to buy them
is this Sunday 100% goes to the crew mhm
and um we have a applaud for that we
have a final
advert for the cards if you want to roll
it I oh we have a new one by the way I
loved that original one yeah they've all
been great so we got a third one let's
see Hello every year multiple podcast
producers miss out on lunch and snacks
because they were too distracted to
place their
order every year without you even
realizing a podcast producer goes hungry
because they failed to put their order
in for some overpriced Aral salad or
unnecessarily sugary B drink these
producers slip through the crack company
expense meals look at this face gaze
upon it what do you see
sad me
too but for just one pack of H3 podast
trading cards you yourself can help
feed hey can I have
this don't let this poor camera Miss
during these final 24 hours a pack of H
trading cards we might just let this
podcast producer have a $25 avocado J
cleansing smoothie do it for do it for
podcast producers
everywhere all right well then you can
just stop it if it's playing twice play
it again when we fix
it um apparently that it was playing
twice it was very funny I I saw it I was
loving it maybe they were laughing twice
maybe it's so funny we played it twice
wait can you unmute it I want to hear
what it sounds like are you sure it's
not horrible it's just slightly delayed
and
double it's not that it's listenable
it's not like un but how come that
happened I don't know tested it right
before the show and was fine that's not
fair that was so funny you want to BR
you want to try
again I mean not without figuring out
why I did that so I mean that was a the
role of a lifetime Dan I'll post it on
Twitter maybe could play it again later
at the 30 minute Mark after we yeah we
could play it we could put it at let's
put it at in a sponsored spot wow yeah a
paid spot right there for you guys think
again sunshine so brave thank you but
very good so you guys can go buy those
at um Dan you're so brave in those
videos yeah thank you can I say Dan was
very impressive he remembered all those
lines yeah like that was like first or
second take yeah he's a thespian you
guys don't know that he's a he's a
classically
trained
um so that's that that'll be up until
Sunday go to the website which
is um TR rng. shop TR D and. shop thank
you and uh finally I want to shout out
Ela Klein my wife who's sitting beside
me there is a new drop what's the deal
with there's so many drops Ela do you
want to comment on that cuz there's been
like we do a drop every
month
[Music]
um what is the question well cuz there
was like there was like three drops
huddled together in the past couple
weeks wasn't there um um maybe you're
thinking of the sale you're thinking
about the sale wasn't there magic magic
yeah yeah um sometimes that happens
because sometimes when we work on a
collaboration um the process asses take
so long that we don't know the exact
release date it's going to end up
releasing at dude this piece is sick I
love it that's awesome so we sometimes
design those as like a floating
collection but we still have like our
monthly collection as well okay um
because you there were some really
because we could design magic for
October and then let's say gets pushed
to November we'll have nothing in
October people were saying that Teddy
fresh is fast fashion you wanted to
respond to that right yeah I I have been
seeing some people say that and I think
that's just um a misunderstanding of
what fast Fashion Is Us releasing a
collection every month doesn't mean that
it's fast fashion we work on a year-long
calendar and um these are not like
products that are made fast and like
going to fall apart within one month or
one wear yeah that's basically what fast
fashion is and it's usually like giant
quantities and super cheap mass produced
dog quality and ripped off and
stolen designs essentially so basically
what you're seeing is a lot of releases
what that means is just that I'm working
really hard it doesn't mean that it's
fast fashion thank you well the
development window on these is like I've
heard that Sheen does this where they'll
get a new item out in a month or some
yeah Sheen for example Zar they're
like billion our best fashion yeah but
this is a year-long development table
and uh or or longer in some cases one
and a half you know and it's Clos that
are meant to last you know the thing is
a lot of companies they'll do quarterly
drops I think that's more standard but
we've always done the monthly and I
personally have always loved that
because it keeps stuff happening like
disappearing for a actually one of the
reasons we do it cuz a few times I've
asked you should we not do it and you're
like I like it I've been a champion of
the but I know it's not easy too it's a
lot of work very challenging but it's
fun it's there's a sense of newness all
the time and I know people nowadays like
um you're shaking something that makes
sound sorry people like to feel like
they can buy something that's unique and
not everybody can have it and so by
doing a monthly collections we're doing
less quantities of stuff so it's more
limited
quantities and once something sells out
most of the times we don't really bring
it back sometimes we do but for the most
part we don't and so it allows us to
make more and be more creative basically
cuz if we made less products I would
want to order more right so then we
would be more constricted that's true it
would have to be something that I would
want to order a lot of and like this
that we wouldn't make the vest CU it's
like we're not going to sell a whole
we're not going to sell a ton this is
kind of like a it's like a niche a niche
I don't know though if that's true this
is pretty sick sometimes you don't know
I can never tell yeah you don't know but
it's not a risk that I would want to
take right and so it's a a unique
business model but I I think it it's I
think it's really cool if you can do it
mhm but this collection you're I think
you're um snapping off popping off
popping off popping off I think you're
popping off girl I think she is too this
is crazy I love the winter stuff
there's not many times in the year when
you can sell jackets oh you got the
double Teddy pendant mhm oh my God
bestie's necklace oh this is sick but
the um yeah I end up matching today it's
got the lace you want to show yours the
lace
trim oh the lace trim that's super cool
it looks like a Pink Ladies jacket so
cute oh did this come out or is this out
this came out right now uhhuh oh that's
going to kill that's so sick that looks
so good what the
hell yeah we're really trying we're
really trying you know I think this this
scarf face go up is so fun it's like a
giant scarf scarf it but it goes over
the head oh like a hood scarf with
pockets what that's sick yeah wait I
want one of those it feels like a
blanket it's really fun dude that's
awesome yeah it's all super fun
winterwear that's my dress that a lot of
people ask I've been wearing it
basically like all the time if you go up
like one more like up that one so we
were inspired here from like you know
the classic old school um outerwear
companies with the big Heritage that's
been around forever and they always have
like their tapes and the technical
details and stuff so this was the
inspiration here and we made our own
tape and I love how it came the tape
looks so so good I love it man
yeah very nice really good stuff I love
this collection cool a little shirt Jack
sweat a sweater dress
yeah yeah it's awesome so go ahead and
check it out Teddy fresh.com maybe
there's something nice you want to buy
yourself for yourself or someone you
love something nice for uh a beautiful
holiday it is December 1st you
understand what I'm saying I'm wearing a
jacket too you showed it in a different
color but yes oh I've been waiting to
talk about this so I got to collaborate
with one of my favorite artists oh yeah
that's Will Lauren Will Lauren um maybe
if you want to pull up his Instagram
he's super awesome I've been loving him
since before I even started Teddy fresh
and he was probably the first person I
bought art from I have a few from him
wait did I spell it wrong will luren I
thought that's how l a r e oh l a r
yeah yeah I remember we still have his
art up on yeah we have a few at the
house and one at the
office but his and over the years I got
to connect with him on Instagram and
then yeah here he is we finally did a
comics of
Trisha
just
saying um yeah like I think do we have
this one this is the one we have that's
crazy whoops I forgot to post anything
about Halloween so here are all the
spooky Comics I could find in my phone
oh so here's a whole list of
them yes so he did the art on that one I
don't know if you can see it but it's
really really came out great super cool
jacket he used to do comics for
adultswim.com
oh interesting yeah he's super
cool I love his style yeah oh ab's
showing it off and you look phenomenal
in that may I also say his art used to
be my phone screen saver for
years that's good
for um the other thing that I saw that I
didn't comment on I know we're going to
get off this uh in a sec but there was
another these bags look sick too yes
yeah cool all right check it out I've
never worn one of these vest things I
like it it's like I don't have to commit
yeah a whole ass jacket right and you
got the pockets I frankly always thought
it was silly cuz it's like that's
there's no way that keeps you
warm it's like open but it actually does
a little bit in La that actually works
it gives you a little it's heating my
neck up that's for sure and it's a
little um layering piece cuz we don't
get to do that a lot here in La it's a
rainy day out here in Los Angeles oh is
that your first
sound Olivia no girl oh you've been
going I've been going oh keep your ears
up yeah and also I should say at the top
that I feel like absolute doodo because
I got my covid and flu
vaccine yesterday in the same spot my
arm yeah back
injury and also I want to tell you that
I had something really disturbing
happened to
me first why were you bullying what did
I do thing disturbing happened oh that
sucks you're booing me cuz I got
vaccinated Olivia
yeah don't shed your vaccine all
over me man yeah that's disgusting
you're like you're magnetic magnetic
right now I am
magnetic oh so I got first they hit
they jabbed me with the uh covid no
problem yeah then they came out with the
flu one now she it seemed like there was
a lot of flu like I felt that go
in but the weird part was when she took
it out it made like a fart
sound I've never heard of that I've
never seen it in my life it actually it
made me super worried cuz I'm always
paranoid about getting like air bubbl
air bubbles in my blood you got
fart arm dude fart mouth fart arm you're
farting out of everything bro it was
super it was quite loud and like it
ended so fast we're like okay that's it
and I left and by the time I was in my
car I was like God I wish I asked her
what the was that she was acting
super casual about it didn't face her
she was being polite but then I was
thinking like maybe it freaked her out
and she didn't know what to say right
that's scary cuz she's just like a nurse
if that she's just some lady who gives a
shot she probably a nurse yeah yeah
probably a nurse so I did a mad
Googling and it turns out I learned some
interesting things that I'll share with
you all first of all what did you Google
first of all a fart sound coming out
seen my arm farted I said I didn't type
fart I said
um how did I word it I worded it
perfectly cuz I found exactly what I was
looking for does fart sounds from my arm
mean I have
Lupus it took me right to uh the right
page
um God damn it dude this cough
is not going anywhere yeah so what did I
type my my vaccine location made
a
queefed squeaked maybe squeaked I don't
know it can you try and replicate what
it sounded like was it like a yeah like
a high pitch like a little squeaker yeah
that never happened to me no it's
up it was super weird like that it was
loud and your arm are you sure you
didn't fart did you get nervous maybe
the nerv probably thought you did just
rip was being no I think it was quite
obvious no I felt it it was very obvious
that it came from that spot we both knew
it we both heard
it eyes when it happened no I wasn't
looking at her I just left then I was
like whoa what was that cuz you know I
wasn't even thinking about it and then
when I left I was like wait what the
why did my arm
fart and so anyway I went to Google and
I had learned some things first of
all this is good to know to get severely
injured slash dying from air in your
blood it needs to be like a significant
amount okay and I'm talking like in the
order of like a few full syringes of air
because when people die from this it's
rare but what happens usually is
something like an IV bag will something
will go wrong and will start pumping
oxygen in instead of IV fluid yeah and
so it's something like that okay like
catastrophic air it's not like one air
bubble no it won't cause you any harm so
that was interesting that was nice to
know cuz I'm an air bubble hater one
less thing to worry about the other
thing I learned because that's
intravenous the other thing is if you're
injecting into the muscle tissue then
air doesn't matter at all oh yeah oh you
can just blow that up like a b it
doesn't matter at all yeah because it
doesn't it doesn't go into your uh
circulatory system I see but another
thing I learned is that when it when
your arm apparently makes a farting
sound it's
more uh if what's the word effect uh the
efficacy it's more effective yeah the
effective they said the efficacy goes up
when your arm makes a farting sound
swear nobody said that I swear I'll look
for
right that I have to read how did they
phrase part it was like a whole meta
analysis with way too like specific like
what I'm telling you how often are
people's arms farting hold on let me see
you're just so good at everything you do
yeah your Co shot is just better than
everybody else that's not the route I
was taking you receiv the vaccine better
than all of us no that was so good at
getting shots no she did something I
didn't do anything I was just
sitting there you just think she has The
Immortal Technique she just like well
she knows my fault I was just sitting
there bro you're more defended to co
than all of us because your arm that's
sick let me find the hold on my
arm uh made a
squeak squeaking sound when I
got a vaccine something like that I
typed um are you asking chat dude here
it is you haters all right the
first result by the way
it check this out squishing sound heard
following an intraarticular shoulder
injection with fluid and air is
associated with higher efficacy a
retrospective
analysis that is a look at this dude
this is the National Library of you
describe what at no point did you
describe a squishing sound well no they
wouldn't write fart well I said it was
squeaky I squeak is different silly
what's the medical term to far
flatulate a flatulate sound let's see
accurate accuracy of blind
intraarticular injections for the
shoulder is rather low it is unclear
whether uh accurate injections for
capsulitis of the shoulder are more
effect they're talking about some other
thing that's not relevant to what I'm
interested
in
results um 61 patients were selected
squishing was heard after 47 injections
77% 2 weeks after the
injection positive outcome was reported
for 49 patients that's more than got the
injection when squishing was heard the
effect was positive in 42 of 47 patients
when no squishing was heard the effect
was positive yeah so they're they're OB
they're talking about some specific
procedure that I don't care about chat
is saying that this is talking about
joints don't care joint yeah it's
talking about oh it's talking about
joint squish yeah no like um intra
articular that's just in the muscle
isn't it I I'm pretty sure that means in
the muscle and intravenous is in the
vein uh
intraarticular occurring or by entering
a joint say it again uh occurring within
or administered by entering a joint okay
so like obviously yeah it's
not it's not exactly right it sounds
like it might not have anything to do
with this but that being said it
certainly it might have nothing to do
well it might but it also may not I mean
maybe we've learned at least from this
that squishing can be a
positive The Joint I think your arm
mostly just queef
dude I mean okay you didn't do
anything uh here introduction capsulitis
of the shoulder is a common condition in
middle-aged people why are you telling
me that I just don't care about that
tell me about the covid vaccine did they
just call you
old I don't know I don't I don't know
what capsulitis is capsulitis is
characterized by pain especially at
night what old idiots that literally
sounds so old get squished get
squeaked somebody said that uh
they're a doctor and that what you're
describing is something that happens
when you eat too much
Denny's thank you Doctor how about you
get back to your residency and stop
watching the show don't you have better
to
do last the last time a doctor called
into the show it did not work out well
for
him he ruined his whole life for
a gag
oh man we got to remember we have to
honor him yeah I don't know if people
even remember what we're talking about
we cut it from the episode too because
he asked us yeah but I think it's all
good now I mean I don't know it's all
good in terms of us I think he did
probably get if not fired like seriously
reprimanded he um is a doctor well first
of all he was a
psychiatrist and he was telling us all
kinds of like totally inappropriate
things about he was like
and diagnosing people yeah which is nuts
that's like super unethical and then he
was like we found his social media and
he's jacked like this dude cares so much
about his body so I asked him can you
take your shirt off and show us what you
got and he called from the hospital by
the way he called he did this in the
hospital and he took his shirt off and
was showing him off his physique which
is be it is beautiful but apparently the
word got round to his employer and uh he
he emailed us begging us to remove it
which was a cuz I loved it I
thought it was so funny but we removed
it for him we did cuz I didn't want to
him over but seems like it didn't
matter herel you're fired although maybe
it's better for him because when he when
he goes to a new when he inevitably
moves States because he needs start
over uh he they won't have like easy
access to the URL M I'm looking out for
him I wonder if he's a still fan after
all that I saw him on the subreddit
after doing the hot chip challenge him
and his girlfriend I believe so that's
good I hope that it didn't sour him
because he was a fan and he was a I mean
he was a a little histrionic perhaps but
we love hisonic people here he took a
risk that I'm sure he was aware
of well risk for what just to show us
his muscle The Exchange on that was not
good it was so fast too you jokingly
said it and immediately Boop he took it
off yeah I didn't expect him to do it he
was waiting for his que cuz he was in
like the um conference room
Hospital can you
imagine doctor
uh yeah but at the same time I've been
watching so much True Crime and uh these
doctors are there's really bad
doctors just what we watched last night
yeah and so like let's give him a break
for taking his shirt off and being a
little silly I mean there's doctors that
are actually killing people out there
let's and then they always get passes at
least in the shows I watch I'm not a
doctor I'm a somebody said
his intrusive thought won that day yeah
not good not good we have to confront
our our intrusive thoughts and battle
them our doctors should not listen to
their intrusive thoughts if there's
anybody in this world oh I just want to
stab him with my scalpel right now I
wonder what would happen if I just like
this instrument I'm a true comedian so I
guess I better stab him in the neck it's
funny it's
funny okay where are we we took a quite
a tangent where are we um uh we are at
30 minutes is where we
and you know what that means my friend
let's just do another five oh okay sure
um let's do a tight five let's do this
one this was a great thought provoker
here um and this guy is speaking to my
soul I think all of us frankly except
maybe love and Olive right maybe Sam
Maybe right how old are you
Sam oh we go to how do
she she's uh 25 yeah she this might not
apply to her yeah and how old are you
Ian 28 29 29 robbing the cradle a little
bit don't you think oh my God yeah why
don't you hit the button on that one
what does that mean I'm just kidding I'm
just they you guys are full-blown adults
you want me
to okay yeah it's just it's just a joke
understand the joke oh it's robbing the
cradles when somebody's dating someone
too young for that
oh yeah right no you guys are fantasttic
you guys are perfect L
aged now it would be now now Ian it' be
a problem if you were like 20 and she
was 16 but that's a huge difference and
that's not what happened at all why
don't you just keep going let's dig into
it further I like I like this tangent
here bro I'm covering for
you all right let's get on with the '90s
kid so he's speaking to my soul
here I mean me and Ela are three years
or almost yeah two and a half car a
little bit aren't you yeah sure yeah by
the same logic yeah how how old's your
girlfriend Dan uh she's one year younger
than me oh robbing the cradle little
don't you
think all right here he
is '90s
Trends you love the '90s so much go away
for the bus go away for the bus with no
cell phone or anything look at your feet
look at your feet for 10 minutes and
look up at the tree
yeah go you're boarded go look at your
feet again what else you going to do you
going to take a rock throw it at a stop
sign for 25 minutes you love the 90s so
much you got you you then go wait go sit
after soccer practice and your mom is
late and the coach took all the balls
and you're cold and you're
sweaty sit there just kind of look at
your feet a little bit just look back at
the goal
posts and look back at the feet and look
go look at the curb kind of sit on the
curb maybe and look up at the fence you
love the ' 90s so
much kids so true I mean we think back
on the Intolerable childhood that we all
suffered through I used to walk at like
6 a.m. about probably almost a mile to
the bus stop freezing nothing to
do you sit on the bus nothing to do you
know what we did we destroyed the seats
in the
bus people just were picking at him
and taking out the CU what are you
suppos what else you supposed to do oh
thank you
Sam oh
I I wanted to get no Boba oh really but
I want Boba with no Boba the bobas might
be the
problem well think I'm having a boba
craving you guys but it's hard to not
suck the Boba it's really hard keep the
straw levitated the whole time dude it
doesn't work I'm telling you try it That
Boba is wants to be eaten so bad cuz
it's delish I've been wanting a boba
like every day lately that is unreal I
got 25% taste this before you taste that
one and tell me if it's
sweet cuz I feel like people mix this
people were with me I feel like
last time they told me that wasn't sweet
I learned you have to mix real good
first okay but that would make it even
more sweet cuz I think the sweet on
bot you're getting all the sweet at once
it sinks to the bottom and then your
first sip it's like all sugar first sip
it's like terrible it okay it's let me
do it go
ahead it's pretty sweet
mhm let me try mine yours is sweeter
yeah but okay it's good though okay do
not waste that sweet milk I'm trying to
be hot in this vest Ela not trying to B
myself
out anyway yeah I mean and I saw
the comments are real interesting too
like you remember just like taking a
dump as a kid you what do you do you
read the shampoo bottle over and over
and over again and then when there's a
new bottle or a new cream or something
to read you get excited you get to read
something new that's what happens yeah
no you're right about that well when you
wait for somebody to pick you up and
like you don't even know if they're
running late or just for something Happ
here let me see go wait for the bus
without a cell phone um if do you have a
question about something just wonder
about it and don't ever find the answer
[Laughter]
that's my
life yeah no it is interesting how how
our Idol time has completely transformed
within within a lifetime you know how
not even a lifetime you know half a
lifetime I uh I had a um a Walkman from
a pretty young age though so like
because I wrote my bike to school and I
would have my uh with cassettes dude
dating myself big time it was a hand-me
down my dad's old Walkman he gave me a
cassette Walkman true true that's true
we did have music yep I didn't I
remember I got a CD player P CD player
in Middle School bro I had a portable CD
player that was a big upgrade you
remember they would always break of
course they were dog CDs were
always skipping on the bus CD players I
mean it's a spinning disc in a in a
transportable form it's probably doomed
to be a little glitchy you know but on
the small bump it would just interrupt
the whole the best part of the
song uh this person says you had no idea
if your mom was running late or just
forgot you so true so so true how about
going to a concert or amusement park
getting separated from your friends and
then spending six hours looking for each
other God pre cell phones was a golden
age you literally just went places and
hoped for the best that's so true
true you want to watch TV you're on
schedule hope you enjoy 50 sitcoms at
two in the afternoon yep okay Boomer
there it is so yeah 90s kids can you
relate to that at all love or Olive yeah
I think so yeah part of I mean before
you had a cell phone yeah yeah I didn't
have a phone until I was
probably 11 12 13 or something like that
oh I mean that's not too much they were
available you just weren't allowed to
have it I don't I don't think there was
well I had a little flip phone or some
like that when I was really young
but never had a smartphone until they
didn't even have that probably 14
my I got a flip phone when I was like 16
and that was like a big big deal
right a big deal bro I didn't even ever
get I've said this before but I didn't
get my first smartphone until we were
living in Israel we were yeah we were in
our 20s and we bought some Chinese it
was like a bad one too it wasn't a real
bro it was it was horrible yeah we got
like aftermarket Chinese ones for like a
hundred bucks mhm that was
expensive bucks a good deal though so
well it worked frankly yeah bar I had a
phone they called a firefly and it only
had three buttons one for Mom Dad police
oh God like the old like the old
people's cell phone yeah Jitterbug
Olivia had Obama
phone but when I my when I was able to
finally buy my own phone I think maybe I
was like 18 or 19 I got the pink
Motorola flip one the razor still it was
a razor my mom you dropped some that was
the phone dude expensive with it that
and the
sidekick my for real you know what
I loved as my first cell phone I had was
this Motorola the one that's the size of
a Twinkie it's indestructible you had it
when I met you I are you serious holy
yeah it was so funny that thing has
had been with me a decade it was like
super narrow oh no not that one not that
one no let me show you that one was a
weird phone that was a weird
phone I don't know how I ended up with
that I think I got it cuz it was so
absurd looking yeah I think you did you
thought it was funny thin
flip
motor
Rolla I don't know maybe some of y'all
remember this thing was so weird that's
no it's not the it was thinner yeah yeah
it was even thinner than this I don't
know so bizarre I've never seen it
before it was like the width of my
thumb oh yeah I had one like that fly it
open like that way yeah like a like a
switchblade that's the pink one yeah
that's the razor oh that's sick so sick
wait you know about the Razer yeah that
was the phone dude yep that was no this
is the one ela's talking about yeah
right yeah yeah they're talking about
that but you're no I didn't have that
cool are you talking about the
pebble Ethan the pebble let's see I
think it was
Motorola
Pebble see no oh no does look like a
Twinkie so that's a good guess this so
no no it's not that one
are you sure it wasn't the noia one cuz
you said indestructible when I think
indestructible cell phone this is the
one that I think of you remember these
yeah that's the one I'm talking about oh
yeah so it's Nokia it's not Motorola
that's the one I had for a deade yeah I
knew lots of people with this one you
could slam this thing against a br a
brick wall and be totally fine crazy
typing on it was insane because text
messaging was a new thing and you had to
push each letter time yeah yeah yeah was
crazy dude yeah and we used Tope m all
my friends used to have that and I would
take it from them for hours to play The
Snake Game true oh my God brick breaker
on the blackberries I used to play that
all the time maybe it's thin maybe it's
a noia then me and Dan were just talking
about this the other day about how it's
weird that just a certain amount of
people at a certain age have that skill
of typing yeah T9 baby I was so fast I
was so fast at it too it's crazy there's
a moment that's just like a whole little
mechanical uh skill set that tons of
tons of humans Le for like 5 years whoa
what the is that thing I'm I'm
still trying to find it what it was so
funny like did you not see I I was
pulling it up earlier here is this it
this one right oh that's it wait Ela
found it okay hold on or like that's a
version of no that's it that's the one
okay that's for sure the
one send it how'd you find it what'd you
Type I Type and there
phone that oh what the hell to open it
is aoto or Samsung oh yeah
Samsung what the this flips down it
covers the keypad it like rotates around
yeah it rotates around whoa and then
when you open it it's a tiny thing it is
so small it's really
dumb it's so dainty against your ear
it's like a switchblade it worked
exactly like a switchblade it's the
goofiest phone I've ever SE it really is
it really was just really up nice
there it is oh yeah here there it is the
Juke wait 2007 let's watch a review
oh it's called The Juke yeah last phone
announced oh my God you Juke in Hebrew
is like
cockroach that's pretty good appropriate
this is actually real interesting here's
a pre a review a preview he by Veron 16
years ago it has 300,000 views not bad
Phone Scoop Wireless is the Samsung Juke
which you can see here resembles more of
an MP3 player than a phone taking a
quick spin around the Juke it has a
control dial here which you can use to
access its
systems do you think it's called a Juke
cuz it's so fast and
nibble Juke
youe on the left is a headphone jack as
well as the data port and lock key too
hot nothing on the bottom and on the
right side of the phone are the
volume jog buttons what opening the Juke
is a matter of switch blading it up like
this you can see it's a very long form
factor when switch blading it up like
buttons oh yeah you D it open the Juke
is a matter of switch blading it up like
this you can see it's a very long form
factor when open and
narrow the keypad is made of a shiny
silvery material that actually feels
pretty good on the
thumb
this jog dial is used to navigate and
you can hear it clicking as it slides
around hitting the center will bring up
the
menu so you can see here no it's way too
low resolution clear key will always get
us back to the uh home
screen yeah I ain't see dude yeah
it's like a phone that was made simple
matter of I think I'm the only one that
owned it too I never met another person
that owned this
like ever what' you send me here
[Laughter]
Sam LG Rumor
Reflex 3G vintage cell phone touch
slider 512 megabites let's go dude I
love that they say
vintage yo 12 bucks 12 bucks I got my
first phone when I was in I think 8th
grade which I feel like it's kind of
late now what age is that
that's like end of middle school yeah
the last like yeah like 13
yeah I wonder when we'll give our kids
that I don't know I don't want them to
feel like weird Outcast CU like there's
there's a balance where it's like
there's some parents that are like
weirdly uh overly protective and then
they're like all their friends have
phones and they
don't and then you know that doesn't
lead to anything good whatever weird
up they're gonna they're
going to look at it on their friend's
phone you know right so there's that
it's also safer to have a phone in a way
cuz like when you go somewhere you
probably get him a non-smartphone okay a
beeper Firefly the yeah I was about to
say the one Olivia was talking about for
when they're like in elementary school
are they going to made fun of if they
have that in elementary school I mean
like a second grader is going to like
are they already bullying you for not
having an iPhone in second grade wait
know it's been a long time since i' been
in second grade wait hold on I'd love to
get Teddy that if the three buttons how
do you call that Firefly I don't know if
they still make it I would love to get a
phone call from Teddy how cool is that
he's so cool he's going to be hitting
you up all day you can call me anytime
Firefly
phone I wonder please don't let them be
an iPad kid I have I have bad news for
you well they they are they already are
no we're we're I mean we're trying I
don't think to balance I don't think
it's really a bad thing our kns
Dalia is like a genius exactly she is
knows so much they learn so much she
knows how to speak so well for her age
as well yeah you know what 100% that's
one our boys are so smart both of them
one of the reasons why I am cool with
them using technology pretty not as much
as they want but like I'm not I don't we
limit it sometimes when we are like okay
not no but the majority of time he's
doing something like when he plays these
games he's doing like super complicated
and he's he's you know learning how
to
coordinate hand eye coordination you
know and um it's it's really quite
impressive so Bruce that is going to be
too soon but he's not yet too he knows
how to navigate YouTube yeah like he'll
swap videos it's crazy to see he learned
to do the iPad before he could talk he
already figured out how to open the
video game on the iPad he will close
YouTube and open the
game it's so wild dude but I think yeah
I I I agree uh AB I don't think it's
necessarily bad I do think that like I
noticed sometimes we would give Bruce
his tablet and he would just get like
super he never wanted to watch anything
he just wanted to be click he would
watch it for like 10 seconds and he
click it and I was like this I don't
like that because his attention span is
it's going to damage him and so when he
starts doing that take the phone and do
something else yeah I so I try not I try
not to ever let that
happen um that sounds like a moderate
approach midle ground yeah I think so
it's
technology this is cool though that'd be
super cool if Teddy had one of these I
didn't realize it was so binary I wonder
if they have uh gay fireflies they
should wait cuz it's Mom dad that's so
good yeah 2005 though man those
different days brother sister sister
nonb sibling can I get a modern
day modern day Firefly somebody said
that they have a smart watch for kids
they can call the parents oh my my
nieces all have those here you go check
these out
yeah yeah here oh they have cute phones
oh we should buy one for Teddy
actually
it's kids SmartWatch with a Tracker oh
that's so
cool most modern phones too have like
you can lock them down so it's basically
just two buttons on a touch phone oh
that way you can unlock it gradually oh
dude he's going to be so stoked we
should definitely get him one of these
this is
awesome I remember I was one of the
first kid dinosaur one oh that's cute
yeah when I was younger I I was one of
the first kids that had like a phone
from my cousins and like my friends and
and we they would always want me and
myself I would look up the dumbest
we were like JLo
sexy and they'd be all crowded
around me looking it up oh my God good
times me and my brother used to do that
when we had dial up we close the door
get all shady we type like boobs or
something boobs and then it would load
so slow oh
God damn I forgot we can't get him one
until Bruce can have one cuz Bruce will
freak out if Teddy has one and he
doesn't Bruce can have
one I mean he doesn't he won't use it
but he can have
it so anyway somebody said Oh wait
I got to do the sponsor I don't
want to drag on too long yeah oh that's
good cam the thumbnail that's good
really good all right let's thank our
sponsor is Shopify who we
love we love love love love
Shopify love them absolutely love them
uhhuh why do you love Shopify because
it's the most reliable platform I've
ever encountered that we've never had
any problems and that is not an
exaggeration and even just now we went
through a Black Friday Cale you know
those have huge amounts of traffic of
people coming into the website and it
went on without a BP 100% up time yeah
it's never been down for me
never um not only does it never cause
problems it's just full of solutions and
of life if you're looking to create an
e-commerce store you must use Shopify
because you'll be doing yourself a
disservice if you use anything else um
it's so intuitive just you can tell
smart people made it because it really
can accommodate anybody mhm well you
know it's worth mentioning that when we
made teddy fresh we asked around to get
a gauge on which platform and we heard a
lot of people people saying hey you
should try this this mhm um Shopify and
um from day one neither of us has any
experience coding or making a website or
anything like that and this was years
ago too I mean six years ago now
something like that maybe yeah six years
and so we were able to create an online
business yeah basically with no prior
knowledge to take online orders and then
at first my my plan was like this could
be hobby this could be just for the fun
I don't know so I made it as basic as
possible pretty much in the beginning
with not any expectations of what might
become of it and I love that we've been
able to just over time grow with the
platform and Elevate our our functions
and the behind the scenes stuff and all
without causing any like never any
downside to the customer or even making
it notice the website going down bugs on
the website nothing ever Shopify is the
global Commerce platform that helps you
sell at every stage of your business
that's another thing from day one to
today it has been the best MH uh from
the launch your online shop stage to the
re first real life store stage all the
way to the did we just hit a million
orders stage Shopify is there to help
you grow whether you're selling scented
soap or offering outdoor outfits Shopify
helps you sell everywhere from their
allinone e-commerce platform to their
in-person POS system wherever and
whatever you're selling shop F got you
covered that's another thing um the POS
system is awesome like when we do popups
we bring that and then we just used it
at updates our our inventory mean at
complex con super
cool um here's something interesting
Shopify helps you turn browsers into
buyers with the internet's best
converting checkout 36% better on
average than other leading Commerce
platforms and sell more with less effort
thanks it's Shopify magic your AI
powered allar I still need to I really
want to F try that I actually don't know
what that is yeah I want I want shop
magic AI powered
Allstar going to take a note oh yeah we
got to
tell yeah let's look into that but
anyway I love them I I can't genuinely
endorse them enough and thank you for to
them for supporting our show as well
that's that's
wonderful yeah
yeah I would honestly give them the same
amount of um endorsement if and if it
was for free um but it's really nice
that they are supporting us yeah love it
yeah so uh let's get started on Shopify
guys if you have any interest in
starting an e-commerce platform this is
the time the place to do it
um sign up for a $1 permon trial period
at shopify.com after dark all lower case
go to shopify.com
afterdark now to grow your business no
matter what stage you're in shopify.com
after dark thank you thank you to our
wonderful
sponsor thank you thank
you please consider uh supporting them
love
them
um goly so I guess we should do one of
the main things now cuz we we have like
three really long things I want to do
which is
the the music
rap and then
watching Elon and then watching Matt rif
and Jordan Peterson I like that order
you want to do that but then big Nick
with the demons we can do that on Monday
I guess Evergreen yeah so let's do the
uh Spotify wrapped then okay
[Music]
um so let's see
here now would be a good do you have the
game music uh music game show
music I must you it's there
yeah really gets me in the mood really
gets me going welcome
everybody to the H3 podcast varod who
Spotify rap is that that's right today
me and Ela your host will be looking
everybody this is just the same this is
the ad music again oh this one was
labeled celebration it was different
wait game show just start playing Just
sample a
few that's the one cam that's the
one
everybody game is
this looking over the
Cru
anonymized uh Spotify raps and trying to
determine r is that and I'm not talking
about tortilla
rap so before we begin we'll start by
showing you
um ours ours cuz we're we're choosing so
still looking back there is this it no
waiting room like
waiting waiting with a little spice
Mario
[Music]
music okay Ethan there's a comment here
God Ethan is so hot dude somebody keeps
spamming that no somebody it's the same
person it's stop doing that I swear to
God there's one person there's one
person that keeps spamming that and it's
like okay yo can we a good time say what
that's the m music and in Olivia's
defense she looking for a song and does
not know the name of it we were that
one's good I like that one like the we I
mean it'll work that might be
copyrighted though oh maybe but
it's in his it's in his like regular de
uh yeah I think that one's okay people
YouTubers use that all the time yeah and
also yeah Zach purged his library of
anything that got claimed so okay cool
probably okay it's still not the right
music though that's that's weird cuz
Nintendo's so notoriously yeah usually
um well maybe let's not risk it I guess
don't risk it okay turn off turn it off
turn off I did I did I did what do you
want me to do Ethan's so hot people it's
like what do you want me to do take it
in
enjoy it
no it's not it's what do you want me to
do with that show them your
Crocs oh true that's what you do this is
dadcore oh wow hell yeah dude these are
my new what are those frog I cruise and
Crocs exclusively these
days no I got to give it up to Sam she's
the one that tipped me off to these and
we got them together
We're In It Together are you going to
wear these out in public Sam hell yeah
these are my dailies I'm not meet
anymore yeah these are my dailies so
your dailies yeah I think they'll become
mine too I like I was saying I'm pretty
much an exclusive Croc wear and these
are going to move up usually I wear
these kind of cool I like these ones
this is appropriate music for those I
like the little the black and white
Ethan and Teddy got a matching pair that
was really cute yeah you wear those
though they're small now ah um I F strap
the jibit got the um the nose and the
Shrek ears they really know what they're
doing at Crocs I got to tell you uh yeah
dude
they're they're killing it dude so there
it is love
it okay so let's go ahead and take a
look at our shop of Spotify or well no
our YouTube music One
frankly oh
shs H shrocks shrs Shrek Crocs shrs shs
shs so I was I was a little bit
surprised by mine cuz I guess I usually
how I listen to music is like I'll
obsess over something for a long time
until I can't hear it anymore M and then
I move on so I don't necessarily
remember what I was listening to at the
beginning of the year
mhm but anyway here it is Ethan Klein
here's your top five
artists wait oh MC Miller's number
one 20 hours is that a lot I don't know
over a year 20 no we don't get to listen
to music a lot actually yeah I don't
that's my other thing like in the grand
scheme of the year yeah because we're
like with the kids most of the time so
we watch kids stuff listen to podcasts
or daily or things like that and there's
not a lot of time to listen to music no
so MC Miller I just discovered him this
year kind of and really liked his music
Kendrick Lamar Tupac baby
Keem The
Beatles you did have a Tupac moment out
of nowhere you were like yeah I was
Tupac all the time yeah dude some of
those old some of his uh jams are so
good oh yeah
um you were in the top. 4% of Kendrick
Lamar listeners Jesus okay cringe no not
cringe you listen to them 21 times as
much as the average listener geez Louise
I do love Kendrick I think he's the best
he's the
best okay this is embarrassing I don't
this can't be true your top albums were
Hamilton girl that's my sister right
there there's no way that's true I don't
know how that got
there and then Mr morale and the big
steppers which is Kendrick's new album
to pimp a butterfly it's always belongs
on your top list section 80 and damn
okay guess I've just been listening to
kendri um here were your is this yours
okay so now it's mine all right so this
one is ela's you want to narrate it okay
so it turns out my top five were number
one Frank Ocean and then Mac Miller and
then Crazy
Frog and then kid Cy and jcole yeah
B Cy when do you listen to
that um listen this this knows better
than me okay yeah you're right your top
albums were what the is this K TR
and
hold on it says you listen for 33
minutes by the way I I listen even less
than Ethan because a lot of times we're
together so whatever he's listening to
I'm listening to what does KRA me it's
um am is a he's a
musician oh it's is they're non- English
speakers no oh I thought this was looked
like I think that's just the art oh
okay
uh here comes the cowboy MC Dem Marco's
album which I really liked so Marco
music It's Always A vibe um and Portugal
the Man Chris black changed my
life yeah I remember listening to that
yeah these were your top five tracks of
2023 pink and white I was definitely
obsessed with that song for a good time
a good amount of time your stats are
pretty weak though I have to say in
terms of volume 11 total listens that's
what I'm saying I don't get to listen to
a lot of music and whenever I have free
time I'm catching up on the H3 podcast a
lot of times if we're in the car
together I'm an H3 podcast listener
first of all first and that's the real
rap and that's a rap um in truth though
when we're together a lot of times it'll
play on myone
yeah but shout out Axel F crazy
frog um every day I do love that one
Tricky by uh Crazy
Frog what does the fox say Bruce loves
that one oh really what does the fox say
he loves it how do you feel about that
that song I don't get it I think it's a
kids song right yeah when it it's a song
for like babies it was a huge deal when
it came out I was in like middle school
or something super embarrassing so
annoying but it's super
embarrassing if you're not like 3 years
old yeah people loved it for a second
that's wild but they did it on Glee
really that was yikes Bruce loves it so
but you know whatever whatever the kids
want to listen to that's what we listen
to you were in the top 3% of Crazy Frog
listeners also they blurred out his
little his little oh what I didn't even
notice that that's
funny wait frog he hangs D okay so this
continues into someone else right the
Frog hangs dong the Frog hog dude all
right so Gabe what's going on buddy how
are you yeah I'm in this intermitting
fasting 72 hours I'm on day two I'm
toughening out that's not intermediate
that's just fasting fasting like fasting
like I'm trying not to eat for 72 hours
to's see if it's going
help right but inter intermediate
fasting means you eat you only eat for a
few hours you eat like once a day or
something oh yeah you're trying to not
eat for 72 hours I'm trying to it's like
a challenge for me oh my God I'm I'm
trying to I'm trying to be I'm not a
I'm trying to be
tough how deep in are you
Gabe I'm I'm thin I'm like really thin
I'm like I'm like down to 156 157
wow but Gabe how how far into your
72-hour fast are you I'm like in the 48
okay so you one more day wow that's
crazy so are you drinking are you
drinking water drinking a lot of water
water helps me hydrate and stuff and
fights the headache and blurry vision oh
that doesn't sound good oh my God uh
blurry vision doesn't sound great maybe
you should work your way up to this
maybe just two days damn he only one day
left though
Dan right I mean you know it's a
challenge do you have can you eat like
uh or can you drink like lemon
water um just water straight water no
lemon not
lemon and have you lost a lot of weight
already in those two days
i l a few pounds that's about it I mean
that's a lot depend on your body that's
a lot for one day yeah definitely is
this
healthy I'll say yeah but it's a
challenge I'm G to see how it
goes I'm see how my body is if if not
you know it's better it's better it's
better to listen to your body but I'm
taking the chance to see if I'm tough
that's I'm a man that's why I'm
taking this you're not somebody call you
a where from has someone been
making fun of you for that Gabe no no
this just a CH yeah I agree you're
not a you're you're far from it
you know I mean
shirt so what are you going to eat when
you break the
fast from I'm gonna celebrate with some
duck baby some duck good old F duck
and are you dreaming about
that
duck oh yeah looking for ahead for
tomorrow wow that's what my FAS duck
duck duck or ribs duck or ribs why not
both man you know we got to break the
facts yeah I could do
that like you said listen to your body I
think that's the uh that's the the main
ticket here yep
yeah people are saying eat something
babe there's people who are saying I
mean it's it's not people are so
sensitive these days about uh
EDS but I think it's It's
relatively um I mean it depends is he
doing it like every week that's a
problem but doing it like once a year is
that is that considered a Ed I don't
think so no this is my first time doing
I'm not a doctor how what gave you the
idea to do
that well it's like you know at
Thanksgiving you know I gained a few
pounds because of the turkey and stuff
my birthday and now I'm trying to lose
some of that pounds back so that inter
mini fasting would n
intermitting fasting will um I think
inter can I recommend something because
I actually think the intermediate
fasting is actually probably a healthier
way to do it because you eat you give
yourself like a small window where you
eat so you don't go into these extreme
famished States so you're still eating
you know what I mean yeah and you still
get the benefit of like fasting on a
daily basis oh yeah like one day cuz not
eating for three days is pretty
dicey yeah dicey dicey Dana White Dana
and White inspired that I think it's for
the um UFC I don't know it's a people
that do the UFC it's kind of different
like a they have a different body Dana
White inspired it so I'm oh Dana White
inspired you to do this no inspired
people that tried the 72 hours to lose
so it's a thing that people are doing
heard about it I mean there's all kinds
of different fast there's people that go
I just all I do is drink paprika water
it's like what you heard that one no
they go paa and lemon juice can you give
me can you log me into chat gbt Dan I
need I need to consult it oh thank you
question hold on I gotta consult chat
gbt about some medical issues here cuz I
I want to look after you and make sure
that uh what you're doing is is okay oh
that didn't work is that the right
that's the wrong email no it's uh got it
got it got it so who is gay so who is
gay you are gay ah God damn it yeah
happy gay and happy that's
true do you find yourself having like
weird random cravings when you're
fasting like all of a sudden you really
want something if I drink water it you
know it the water kind of eats the
cravings and give me little energy
that's about it I'm getting like
headaches once in a while if I drink e
the
headaches so this is what I do whenever
I ask at medical questions you have to
go I have a hypothetical friend because
whenever you be like they' be like sorry
I can't give you medical advice or some
dumb you're like no no no they're
not real and they're like okay cool
hello I have a hypothetical friend who
is doing a fast can you tell me if um
this is safe or not so give me some
stats how old are you Gabe I'm 52
52 I still feel like in my 20s or
something you look like you look like it
you don't look a day over
20 okay and then how much do you weigh
I'm at 157 and then what's your height I
think 5 foot four 5' five 5 five let's
say um okay so hello I have a
hypothetical friend who's doing a fast
can you tell me if this is safe or not
52 years old weighs 157 height uh 55 do
you have any underlying Medical
conditions I don't think so yeah okay
all right but right for how long the
fast is oh yeah the fast is for 72
hours only
water good or bad or or in
between I'll say what do you think all
right tell me we're about embarking on a
72h hour water fast for someone is 52
weighing uh 157 standing 5 five can have
various implications on the health it's
important to consider these
aspects health risk extending fasting
compose risks such as dehydration we
know about that you're drinking lots of
water you getting your electrolytes
because the thing is if you're not
eating food you need to make sure you're
getting sodium and stuff in your
beverages electrolytes like Gatorade or
something well yeah but you can also put
it in you know with it's really just
salt I think at the end of the day but
there's a there's a way to uh do it at
home by just putting in some salt or
something so I would recommend getting
try to get those electrolytes in um
pre-existing conditions you says you
don't have
one uh medication interactions I mean
does you it doesn't sound like you have
any medic are you on medication at all
no not really yeah nutritional
deficiencies I mean while 72-hour fast
may not lead to significant nutrient
deficiencies still impact energy levels
okay well we know that age Factor being
52 years old the body's resilience and
ability to adapt to nutritional stress
might be different compared to younger
but you seem to be doing well you're
have the body of a 20-year-old body
composition their weight and height
indicates a body mass index oh I cannot
believe you said BMI chat
gbt and the overweight range wait what
they said chap ggbc said you're
overweight that's not that can't be true
is it or you because you you've lost so
much weight I lost so much
weight it says um might influence how
their body responds whatever consult a
healthc care professional obviously
that's a good idea have you talked to a
doctor about it I did once um I had my
last check up like about a month ago so
oh that's fantastic they said it was
cool to do yeah that's it that his
doctor told him to do it you guys okay
all right clap I mean
uh let's see monitoring it's important
to monitor your health if you get dizzy
fatigued heart palpitations or confusion
you should break the fast what you said
the blurry vision made me a little
worried yeah it's it's a little
bit probably eat something what is the
blurry would that be like fatigued it's
definitely Fue you know your body is not
getting that nutrients you know just
feeding water I think water is the
substitution are you like dizzy when you
after sitting and you get up do you get
dizzy uh sometimes you when I up a
little bit so Gabe I think I think your
body is telling you to
[Music]
eat because it says here modering you
have to keep an eye out for dizziness
fatigue heart bision confusion and other
things which you've mentioned like
blurry vision and dizziness if it starts
to get worse then I got no choice I got
no to break the thing but I gotta listen
to my too yeah I don't want to get in
the way of your goals but I do I do
think you should probably eat something
dude 72 hours is pretty long two days is
a long time enough yeah did you look
great skinny clean looking Beauty yeah
uh let's see here this is an important
one Gabe hydration and electrolytes
staying adequately hydrated is crucial
they should also consider the need for
electrolytes as water alone might not
replenish salts so that is something
that I think you should look into like
immediately
and it doesn't break it doesn't break
your fast just to get some salt in your
water or
something yeah maybe maybe it's I have
that thought about it if the
electrolytes help yeah I think it would
I mean it couldn't hurt and then post
fast care how they break the fast is
also important gradually reinduced Foods
starting with easily digestible Foods is
recommended that may UND that may go
against your duck and Rib
strategy maybe start with a fruit or
something like that that's
something ribs uh it says remember while
fasting can benefit certain individuals
it's not suitable for everyone it should
be approached with caution especially in
the case of longer fast like a 72 hour
water only
fast M yeah I think you should eat
Gabe the
dizziness you're not gonna you're not
going to you're not going to though are
you I can
tell I'm I'm Miss see I'm going to see
I'm going to see what you know what I
can do you know how I can take it if not
then I got no choice I got to listen to
myself I don't want to fake and then
yeah no def you shouldn't even get close
to that frankly it's not worth it I me
it's just one day of not eating what's
the big
deal yeah and you're you're doing great
already without the fast
so I appreciate the love support you
guys are great I love you too buddy
that's why I'm I'm looking after you you
know
yeah the thing is again I'm not a
nutritionist
but um if you've been doing such a great
job losing weight on dieting and
exercising you know that's such a better
healthier way to lose weight than just
fasting isn't really a
sustainable right or even a good way to
lose weight I think because you're just
going to gain it all back immediately
when you start eating again and it's
just really hard on your body you know
what what the freak you should try
intermediate
fasting I'm thinking about that I'll see
is your family there in case you like
pass
out um I have I have some um they
they're way right now I'm by
myself and you're by yourself oh no
don't do it by yourself if they were
there at least come on Gabe eat
something man okay you're there by
yourself you don't want to out and
nobody's there to look after you
yeah you're not going to though are you
I can
tell you
know if I was I was going to let you go
but the fact that you're there by
yourself do you have a Life Alert or
something if you fall and can't get back
up Life Alert I have my phone with me
and stuff or okay I have somebody close
by and something
happens um can we do a poll if Gabe
should eat would that be influential
let's see let's see let's see yeah let's
do a poll um should Gabe eat yes or no
yeah and there's nothing wrong with
breaking a two-day fast you know like
that's that's commendable that's a long
time not eating man that's
crazy I've done 24 and that's really
hard that was for like when we were in
Israel people do um yonip po it's once a
year oh that those people they don't
drink water it's no water and also you
can't no water you can't use any
electricity or anything so it's really
hard so Gabe but um thinking of longer
than 24 that's I can't so Gabe we're
getting some results here 81% think that
you should eat
something okay pretty overwhelming
majority there kind encouraging me to
eat what it we
have 3,000
3,000 votes Gabe and 80% are saying that
Gabe should eat yes they said Gabe
should eat
yes yeah I mean I don't know if you were
there if the fact that you're there by
yourself makes me a little a little it's
a little extra concerning but yeah
you're gonna do what you do and we and
we love you no matter what all right
yeah appreciate the support we're all
right
gabo yeah
so let us know how it goes I guess we'll
check in with you next week and I'm
curious uh if if uh what ends up
happening in the end you know but do the
electrolytes at least because that's not
going to break your
fast just put a little salt in your
water I think right I mean electrolytes
would help there's some store there's a
store that sell the electrolytes that
some like a drink you mean like a
Gatorade yeah like a diet Gat rade zero
calories there's the what is that I
don't Pedialite Pedialite that's the
metal
pedite although I don't know do they
make Pedialite no sugar yeah I think so
they do how to add a draw I don't lights
to my water I mean there's there's a way
to do it at home let's ask Chach B it's
simple they say um you lose salt fasting
it says listen to this Gabe adding
electri to your water is a simple and
effective way to re to replenish
essential minerals your body loses
especially during activities like
exercise fasting or are in hot
water so they're calling you out
specifically um they say commercial
electrolyte tabs do DIY electrolyte tabs
here it says just dissolve half a
teaspoon of water and two tablespoons of
Honey or sugar and one liter of water
this provides sodium and a bit of
glucose
H so basically just salt though and a
little bit of uh I guess a little bit of
sugar you can probably you know but you
know lemon juice also lemon juice they
say provides
sugar lemon juice is a good potassium
additive they're saying coconut water
there it
is what you
want what what were we talking
about I think I know who's on sound
bites now thank
[Laughter]
you
thank you baby I love
[Laughter]
you I'm
just let me talk godamn
it all right take care Gabe we'll talk
to you next week all right love you
listen to
safe all
right listen to your body all right clap
if you think she should suffer you know
people I see the the turmoil in chat
when it comes to these issues so we got
to be responsible about it and make sure
that you know everyone's eating uh uh
responsibly safely I really think he
needs to drink some salt though that's
the one thing I I wish he would do but
it didn't seem like he was prepared to
do any of what my suggestions did it it
seemed open to the he
did not the sugar though yeah the sugar
was too far yeah all right so anyway
back to this
um all right up next this is one of the
crews so this is our mystery one ready
first mystery rap is top artist Young
gleen
Love well let's look at the whole thing
first but yeah that was my first thought
too that's just pure genz degenerate
music right there and we love it by the
way we listen to him too sometimes I
actually he's yeah he's good I used I
like young Le I'm just being
silly uh
Willow wow eeko 2K margerie BL blatty I
don't know who these people are I'm
Boomer blade I mean I know who Willow is
yeah I know Willow I don't know the rest
though dang dang do you guys all know
these bands mhm oh I don't
no most I guess they can't really
comment cuz we're
guessing I can comment but I'm going to
be trying to throw you off well you can
say that you know it it doesn't mean
it's in your top favorite don't listen
to them all right so moving on oh that's
all I get is just their top one yeah I
mean yeah we didn't over want to
overwhelm you with the information here
okay yeah it's love it has to be has to
be real quick I I don't know who the
last person was can I just tell the
audience Olivia asked me to cover her
thank you I didn't take it from me yes
yes I I begged if I'm being honest yes
oh you can just looking for the sounds I
just I felt so bad you were panicking I
was I was choking the entire
time so is this you
love are we doing uh oh are we not wait
till the end wait till the end we'll do
it we have a match up maybe we'll change
our mind as we go all right your top
artist siza is that who you say that
siza yeah look at you hip Taylor Swift
that's a girly probably not to make
judgments CU I am a swift Die Hard
seriously cardi B huh
Ray the ladies represent ice
spice so the T Swift is definitely
a an Olivia is giving Olivia I don't
know Sam it's not it's not Sam it's
either Olivia I know either might be
Lena Lena are you
Swifty I'm not Swifty oh don't
listen to what they say
[Music]
though Sia what's a what's that what's
her popular
song Kill Bill Kill Bill I just killed
my ex
she's I'm just going to listen to a
second of it yo bro I met this high
school girl that excuse
me I don't know it I'm drunk I think
it's probably Olivia I I'm more leaning
Lena
really Split Decision here maybe we can
wait and see the others because we can
put it yeah we can put pin in it you can
pin it all right moving
down the OC's the hell oh this is Dan
King gizzard who else listens I don't
know I never heard of King gizzard
before really yeah I only then you like
it the O se's Jesper
kid what is Jesper kid what this what do
you br hold on who's Jesper kid let me
see what the do you do Jesper
kid he is
a Danish composer and sound designer who
has worked on video games Danish gross
he has we know it's not
love I would never he has composed sound
tracks for the Hitman series Assassin's
Creed Borderlands and Darksiders what
waa okay so this is this is actually a
wild card now I don't think Dan listens
to it could be cam video game music
Could This Be Love could we have made a
mistake no way cuz who who's listening
to video game music could be
cam Cam's not a c Cam's not really a
gamer I don't think like love is a gamer
yeah but this is the music it's not
necessarily playing the game
King
gizard mildlife and
OC's I don't know I think it's got to be
can we keep looking yeah let's keep look
okay okay let's
see Drake oh we got we found you we
found the Drake fan AB Drake Will Smith
bro that has who else would Will Smith
only
bro how are you listen to Will Smith in
2023 it it's not
[Music]
me Drake Will Smith
B Mark Mark Morrison and Tupac
Shakur who's listening to Drake number
one Will Smith that's the one that
really me yeah Will
Smith what does he even what do you even
listen to that one song he just does he
has like one good song The Fresh Prince
theme song
fortnite uh the w w West theme song the
Mi theme song
helloo getting jiggy with it dude jiggy
with it jiggy with it that's the one I
was n n n n dude what about this one he
goes such a good lyric uh the wiki wiki
Wild Wild West this is yeah that's the
Wild Wild West
this has AB written on it no
question I'm offended ab's getting
called out Will Smith AB you're going to
have to explain that one I mean I'm cool
with all everyone else here I like Drake
he's got some good hits for sure Drake
are we assigning that to AB yeah we'll
give it to AB I agree Mark morson I
don't know who that is where is that one
return to the Mac I'm in a sea of
slander and lies Return of the Mac I say
so turn of the okay
oh okay okay okay hold the phone okay
okay I'm glad we
waited Ariana number one Olivia Cyrus
Olivia Selena Gomez all the tops I kind
of like Miley lately all the Disney
girls Miley Cyrus oh that's true they're
all Disney girls Sabrina
Carpenter that's got to be Olive no
question no question
about it whoever this is needs a burner
account it's
happening uh okay that's this one over
here yeah
okay all right so we have three assigned
so far all right nice boy
Genius okay s making another appearance
The
1975 Big Thief Phoebe Bridges oh that's
some I know her she's like pretty
indd this is giving me me Ian or S I was
thinking cam
maybe maybe I don't know what boy Genius
is though what is thate Bridges oh
that's her band yeah who okay so then we
have a Phoebe Bridges fan here I like
legs true we have a Phoebe Bridges fan
here and a legs fan and a S and
S I'm feeling cam or Ian I don't think
it's Sam for some reason yeah
it's getting close to S but I think
there'll be like one more Wild Card
thing added in there hers is going to be
like the Dosey D and the fork and the
the
yipp the yippy yippy
Boogie maybe we'll get back to this one
in a minute all right all right all
right oh God Ariana's in another one Lil
yachty do a Le
is Zach here
Zach is Zach in this Zach is in this
okay
okay got
him that's wait no this is Ian the gex
the G he loves Ariana the grand yeah he
loves her the little yacht wait you're
so right this is Ian this has Ian
written all over it you're so right the
Ariana is the giveaway I didn't I didn't
know he was a du dualipa head who is it
bit I mean he appreciates
icons what kind of music is 100 gex you
call it kids Bob yeah it's kids it's
kids spot music no they're cool they're
awesome I know for a fact that Sam loves
them
but Ian is related to S let's put this
on Ian for now okay uh wait no Kanye
though uh well do auspiciously
missing I did not like it I'm I mean I
sometimes I'll be honest sometimes Kanye
comes on and I'm
like I really love this song it's hard
yeah I mean forget Kanye Michael
Jackson I I I think for Ian it probably
is yeah but like I genuinely believe
that Michael Jackson was a prolific
serial child AR worst but I can't
because but then at the end of the day
it's like his music's still everywhere
and I kind of tap my foot to it you
can't help it that shit's popping we're
all
human yeah the music is too good it's
your body just
responds I haven't played a Kanye song
in almost two years yeah wow and you
don't miss it he's off the stuff he's
got his 24mth coin yeah over it's
amazing I wonder if you'll ever go back
Ian no you're out forever yeah I'm out I
mean maybe if he stopped being a Nazi
and apologize for being a Nazi yeah he
might have Redemption Arc I could
literally say anti-semitic and they
can't drop me well dude that is my
favorite quotes ever now what now what
we learned even more about how crazy he
was behind the scenes recently we
listened to there was a daily about
about how he was the relationship we had
with Adidas and horrific like he used to
go to and Adidas is a German company and
they're super uh sensitive about Nazi
stuff and anti-Semitism for obvious
reason
and so he used to go to Germany and do
meetings and he would pull up like Nazi
and like swastic which it's
literally illegal to do that yeah they
said one time when a designer presented
the ideas Kane to to express that he
didn't like a design he drew a swas on
it that's it's literally illegal to do
that in
Germany but he was showing people
pornography and stuff for like no
apparent
reason and just they had he was such a
horrible personal work with they had to
rotate the designers they had like five
designers on rotation the people who
actually like interact with him they had
to rotate those people cuz they needed a
long break in between cuz he was such a
nightmare to work with that's crazy but
it was yeah yeah going to stop dish the
Nazis all time but it's interesting to
see the the amount of money that he was
making for them they couldn't say no
they couldn't resist even with all the
red flags it their business was so tied
up with him at that point and they kept
going in deeper on relationship giving
him more money and stuff it didn't make
Adidas look great listening to that I
know money money um all right moving on
so this we said is
em Bruce
springin Z
Le Queens of the Stone Dave Matthews B
holy
if you're not your own biggest wait
what why is Creed number two that man
loves Creed Creed isn't Creed the
God yes and like the one that just
sounds like Eddie veter yes isn't even a
meme I he likes Creed I don't know what
to tell you it's it's he's not even
Christian it's not about that dude he
likes the butt Rock stuff you know I
mean Bruce Springsteen's cool you can't
hate on that yeah no no yeah he's got a
great name right I love that name now by
the way I love it I think it's such a
great name Bruce so sick he's so cute
Brucey Creed that's surprising Zack
Lewis hm when I was in high school I got
a Creed shirt and I my parents told me I
wasn't allowed to wear it really they
were like you have you ever heard Creed
before and I was like No And they're
like don't wear that out of the house
why they just don't like Creed oh
they're oh cuz your parents were are in
the music industry yeah they have strong
they're like hell no you are not my
daughter if you are walking out of the
house that's awesome I'm assuming wasn't
under
lab Creed used to be like seen as like a
Nickelback but they're having like a
weird Resurgence now well so is
Nickelback Zach also defends Nickelback
vehemently he loves him look at this
Photograph I'll never get on the
Nickelback train but I'm on the Creed
train all right fair enough praise God I
might still have the
shirt wide
open so I mean this is Zach obviously
not that we're not all listening to Zach
Lewis live I mean
could be anyone of us it could be
anybody absolutely you know big a
machine
gun Tyler the
Creator Teddy
Pendergrass red
Veil Pine grve and Marvin Gay someone's
got
soul Who's in a soul having a soul
moment is this cam could be cam yeah I
felt like cams would be I didn't know
that cam like Tyler the Creator though
that is that's like a very specific
number one you know so who do we have
left the ones you have aside are cam
myself Sam Lena and uh that's it cuz we
know you well between
yours it's not Dan I know that why you
say that what does that
mean I love Mar are you a Tyler the
Creator friend I like Tyler
you're he's not your number one be your
number one no I know that for a fact if
this is Dan I'll eat this Shrek
Croc I'm so sure it's not um so
Tyler I think it's got to be got to be
cam I I think it has to be cam probably
yeah Sam maybe I don't know no this is
not Sam I'm I'm waiting for the perfect
Sam okay we'll put this on cam cam yeah
all right Roger why does he have a QR
code uh he wanted to share uh additional
information about his Spotify wrapped
yeah I mean proud of it everyone's
everyone's all ashamed of their most
played music of the year but if you want
to get was a a shame it literally was
not about a shame been that's been a big
point of conversation in the office not
you guys but I think it's funny it's not
that serious yeah we thought we thought
that having both the top artists and the
top songs would be a lot of information
to like be breaking down and it was just
going to slow everything down we decided
streamline we'll just do the artist but
I I got no shame no sh Dan L and proud
we're done I want to see that okay I
agree with you I think it would have
been too much information to look at but
yeah if you want to listen to my most
played there you go QR code that um
after let's look at the top songs though
okay so yeah let's put this on cam for
now okay have three people left oh wait
okay so we got to go back so we got to
go back okay okay so so hold on so in
that case King gizzards got to be Dan
that one has to be yes that has to be
Dan the dude's got a king gizzard shirt
it's part of his identity everyone's
always talking about King
gizzard if that's not then I will eat
your Crocs thank you well definitely not
all right somebody's eating the Crocs
put your balls in my mouth so what was
the two between uh Sam and Lena okay let
me go find him I'll I'll I'll recognize
him young Le we did that one this this
was one okay so who's the real girly
here Lena has got this locked down
I think so hold on there's this one and
just to compare yeah what's the other
one this this is Dan
no it's the one that starts with boy
Genius is the other one that's available
boy Genius is
Sam mail for Sam Sam you think that
one's Sam no question Sam Sam is just a
real talent that one there and this one
oh
the the the big Swift head okay so it
looks like we got the full uh all right
I'm feeling pretty good range here yeah
I'm feeling so we can start just uh left
to right I guess go
ahead Sam is your top artist boy
Genius yes there it is got that
one uh Ian is your top artist Ariana
Grande that's
right well hold on is your second little
yachty oh yeah is your second little
yachty oh yes all right there we
go wait what do we win if we get them
all
correct uh a big uh props shout out to
the sh out okay uh Olivia is your top
artist Ariana Grande followed by Olivia
Rodrigo yes it is
wow love is your top artist Young lean
hell yeah hell yeah hell yeah
Dan is your top artist the's it sure is
you got that jper kid you looked it up
video game music yeah I guess you're a
gamer you are a gamer so he has he you
just you Vibe with it on okay so the
story behind this is at near the be like
it was almost at the beginning of the
year I was actually surprised that it
was seen this year um I was playing a
game this RPG that uh is similar to
balers gate and the music in the game
sucks
and so I played a soundtrack from a
different gamees music that I thought
worked better than that game so and I
just and I just had that album on repeat
and so and it apparently it played
enough that it wound up as my number two
artist cuz when it popped up I had no
idea who that was I was like who the
is Jasper whatever the now
you're the Biggest Fan I'm one I'm in
his top 1% uh Zach uh obviously this was
Zach yes you got it and uh Lena is this
siza Taylor Swift uh one you that's me
it sure
is and ab are you Drake and Will Smith
yes oh my God is which means you also
got cam which you means you got the
whole thing dude nicely done the
first time we've ever done that a total
clear out Evie what's the deal with Will
Smith how's that your number two okay
are you familiar with Mo Danielle from
90day fiance wait I think so let me look
that sounds very familiar he's like the
biggest piece of he came from uh
where's he from L is from uh Tunisia
Tunisia yeah and he he's like taking
advantage of this middle-aged lady in
Ohio oh no for a green card she's like
madly in love with them let me pull up a
picture cuz I I haven't been up to date
yeah we got of took a break from the
show for a little bit oh I don't know
them mo and Danielle oh my God they're
the best I might have to get back
into that cuz I love that show back
during the we're looking for some crappy
things to watch right oh no you got to
watch I Lena's dad who has probably said
like 30 words to me since I met him sat
down and watched the whole season of
this with me he's never watch anything
with K and he he was commenting too he's
like he's like liar this guy oh shut up
that rocks but anyways that's Miami Mo
um so anytime I would watch clips of him
on stream I would play Miami by Will
Smith and so that's and it happened
enough that your second hard I mean
that's like a Dan
situation okay that that makes more
sense actually there something else
funny about mine that I should point out
is that my the OC's is my number one and
my number five you see OC's it's the
same band they do this really
annoying thing where they they change
the spelling of their name for like
every album and they release a ton
of albums they're like really prolific I
don't know it's just like a it's just a
thing that they do and so my one and
five are actually the same people that's
yeah they didn't figure that out yet
apparently and um
Lena you're such a Swifty
huh I am I mean aren't we all first of
all yes there's only one answer to this
question yeah yeah I noticed nobody's
number one was BTS that's a problem
posers mine was but I you did my I
actually listened to my BTS on the
official BTS app cuz I'm a real fan so
yeah yeah right me too yeah I think a
big reason it came up as one of the tops
for me too is I just wanted to brush up
on like the earlier Taylor Swift because
um I went to the AOS tour screening um
it was hosted by the lers and Nicole uh
consilio took me with her so I just
wanted to make sure I had it all down
yeah dude she she betrayed the family
she hung out with Jacob when we're Team
Edward in our house oh no it's allowed
never did you like the did you like the
show by the way yeah it was really cool
I didn't go to the actual concert but
seeing the movie it looked really cool
oh I see it wasn't the concert itself no
no m and he did backflips right for you
yep he did people kept asking him though
to do backflips so it wasn't totally
random um cam also a little bit of a
surprise Tyler the Creator number one uh
very interesting unexpected for some
reason he rules he just he just
re-released uh his album call me you get
lost but he added some uh new UN songs
on it so I've been listening to it a lot
this year this is a we go through phases
sometimes we listen to him all the time
I when the flower boy or what was it
called flower flower I listen to that
album so many
times but uh okay great and Marvin Gay
huh he's the soul still continues to
live on him and Teddy Pendergrass both
yeah I love yeah there's a lot of soul
and like Tyler's been kind of leaning
into the whole soul angle on his last
couple albums too love
it um am I tripping or I don't see the
like dislike bar on our video but I see
it on yours it's not okay oh uh the
plugin to add it back might be outdated
or something oh interesting no I don't
see the bar at all the bar is like
missing like it was turned off or
something what are we going to do um
what else let's see any surprises young
Leen that's not a surprise at all no
love young Le love young Le uh you were
surprised by the willow yeah I I know
not surprised yeah she's one of
the best artist ever
M I've been seeing her performances come
up a lot of times on my Feit and I
really like it she's so good I love her
out your mouth that is his
daughter it's not your wife yeah Will
Marquez
Marquez and then no surprises there with
Ian that one I I think yeah the Ariana
she survived the purged when Kanye was
purged she continued is that right
Ian what do you mean what you mean he
still listens to her because you were a
huge fan of both of them I think at the
time she hasn't done any like Nazi
no no no I'm saying he still is a fan
people are saying mine is so vanilla it
might as well be Taylor Swift okay first
of all music
snobs sorry if my artists aren't exotic
enough for
you but yeah I mean yeah I like what I
like and I don't what I don't nobody
should be shamed I got I won't single
anybody out but it was a little like
pulling teeth getting everybody on board
with sharing these here in the office
there was a lot of resistance I don't
understand
it it is it is a very personal thing
changes I bet you like ours changes
every year because just it's whatever
you're into at the time right what
happened to Young lean he's got bracers
on and
that's got those epic drops dude he'll
just do the most random those
bracers yeah probably I don't know he'll
just do the most random and I I
don't know he pulls everything off I
don't know one um do we have the the
supplemental information I still love
his old look from the old videos where
it was just like super prep outfit you
know what I mean like just like casual
or very casual all Nike yeah just
Swedish boy RPP yeah uh as for
supplemental information I'll be honest
uh don't want you to take this the wrong
way I figured that getting you to know
the artists was going to be a stretch so
I figured we didn't need the songs cuz
it was too confusing Fair that's fair uh
but we could get it on hand but we don't
have it at the moment I Dro M to Discord
yeah we can move on there's other stuff
to do we have two very long videos to
react to and we're almost two hours into
the show so uh we might want to quit
speaking get one of those going I don't
think we're going to be able to get to
both frankly so which one are we doing
then Elon or let's do a poll and we'll
do that one first Elon Musk interview or
Jordan X Matt reif I just going to throw
my two cents I think the Elon one is uh
more relevant at the
moment it's true let's see what the
people lot of Buzz about it I'm curious
but dude the Matt r one is so funny I
feel like also we don't have time stamps
for that one for the Matt r one right I
was just going to let it run which is
risky
sure watch acknowledge
that I could probably kill the romantic
music at this point oh I forgot I was
on all right which vid should we watch
Elon or Matt R let's
go ooh the votes are pouring in but it's
Clos 5050 whoa wow wow the votes are
really coming in Split here there I'm in
trouble again people that want okay
people get have your voice oh it's back
and forth bro and back again and Back
Again guys this is going to determine
what we do for the next hour or two so
get your votes in people at home we have
3,000 votes populated 54% are saying
Elon must get this moment if you care
about the Matt R Jordan Peterson if you
care about the Elon Musk New York
Times in
now it is leaning Elon yeah it took a
breakway here 54 % is saying we demand
uh Elon Musk we demand it some people
are saying that AB uh wrongly influenced
the poll but that's okay oh yeah we
never do that around here I've never
done it never a
fact okay so that's it we'll do Elon
it's keep it's still going up
55% says watch Elon and that is what we
will
do um God I wonder watch this hrh
collection goes mask off on disabled
people too oh that one's crazy too and
then the big Nick thing I mean I don't
know what to say there's just too much
good content to get to well let me just
click her real fast yeah they want
Elon like I feel really I've not seen
this yet and I I'm aware of her
lore I was telling I don't know eler the
guys when I first found
her she was in this viral clip of her
losing her over something like
totally trivial and it was hilarious and
I thought she was like a comedian and so
I went to Instagram and I followed her
and we followed each other and we I
think we even chatted a little bit cuz I
was wondering if she'd be fun to bring
on the show okay but as I followed her I
I found come to find that um she was
just posting like Maga like like
for real it was not she's genuinely
pretty nuts that girl yeah she's not so
I don't know I don't know where the
comedy ends or begins or if it's comedy
at all I don't know but here let's see
what she said about this this title is
yes girl get that
abortion
Jesus bring this up but it's really
depressing and like I hated I I really
wanted this for like a couple days ago
but like I didn't want to go back to the
mall
because um okay I don't want to be rude
because I'm not being rude I'm just
actually asking a question why are there
so many like like developmentally
disabled
people like not even like kids
there's like groups of like like
developmentally disabled like physically
you more like developmentally disabled
disabled people in like groups walking
around the
mall okay I'm sorry she say she's not
going back cuz she doesn't want to see
them just let it let her cook no offense
I'm sorry this is not a public space
like this mall is already so depressing
as is and then you have to like then I
have to to like see like tragedy do you
know what I mean like okay I know you're
going to be like Al no get the off
of my page I'm not that's when she like
she like splits she like a demon comes
out of her out of nowhere that's what I
thought was so funny what what but I I
can generally cannot tell if she's
serious or not you're real I think she
is serious I think she's serious I think
what I came to find is that she is
serious be pretty funny if it was a
comedy bit I thought so too but I think
she is serious and that's what conern me
and why I kind of sto fell out on her
hey I'm sorry like no offense I'm sorry
this is not a public space like it is
literally small is already so depressing
as is and then you have to like then I
have to like see like tragedy do you
know what I mean like okay I know you're
going to be like Alex no get the
off of my page I'm not kidding I don't
need you to be like you're rude or
you okay this is an actual like don't
tell me you lying that you
don't feel that too okay I'm sorry
hate you you I don't want
to like go somewhere and
like like it's it's very sad okay it's
very sad to me and they're not in there
eating lunch they're not they're walking
around you know how old people do that I
feel like I've heard this where old
people they like to Peru I really just
stunned I mean it's quite a quite a
thing to record and put
online yeah around the mall to get like
watch to walk okay because it's air
conditioned and things like
that okay I don't necessarily agree with
it but I don't care okay I feel like who
made you Queen of the mall why does she
give a she's policing who can go in
the mall and who can't but she said the
mall is already depressing as it is so
like why is she going
there she's not going anymore not after
all the disabled people it sounds like
it's not doing this is not a public
space for you to peruse okay if you're
not shopping get the out that's
what I think um this is a private
property okay that's what I think it's
definitely I mean it is but it's not
your property I think there is actually
a thing I think of private public
property yeah where there's a reasonable
expect yeah yeah mall would definitely
be that yeah for sure so it's not like
I'm discriminating against also do you
own the place do you know the person
that owns place like who the are
you to make the law this is what I'm
saying I can't tell with her if she's
serious or not but it seems like she is
unless so to me it seems serious group I
just think it's weird like why are you
loitering cuz that's loitering okay I
know we have no laws in California
anymore but you can't just walk around a
mall okay so obviously there's like
groups you can't just walk around the
mall that's literally what people have
been doing since the invention of malls
that's the point of the malls you walk
around I was going to say as we all know
historically malls have been a place
where many have been uh dis disallowed
some people go just to look at stuff and
no intention of buying anything
y people can't tell in the chat people
are torn if she's trolling or serious
but
yeah the thing is if she was trolling
like let's say that she doesn't in
actuality agree with what she's saying
and she's just trolling yeah at a
certain point she's been doing this now
for years putting yourself out there
saying this kind of
the effect of it is the same yeah people
are going to judge her because it comes
off as serious so that makes me think
that she's being serious because if she
was trolling I think she would
have maneuvered by now hold on why's my
brush come on that makes me
think it's a ComEd I don't know like
groups right she might actually be that
unstable that's the other thing of like
it's like okay it's like a adult adult
groups of like developmentally disabled
people okay call them disabled but
they're not like physically disabled
they're just like you know do you you
know what I mean okay like bagger Vibe
do you know what I mean like bagger
bagger what does that mean I don't
know what she mean things like that stop
so beggar bagger what does that mean is
it like loose clothes bger not like
physically disabled they're just like
you know do you understand you know what
I mean okay like bagger Vibe do you know
what I mean like bagger boys things like
that bagg boy oh like the bagging person
at the Kier at the checkout at the
grocery store check no that's too
obscene that's what she means I'm pretty
no way hold on boy that they oh
god oh dude she does mean that yeah she
means that yeah amazing cuz I
yeah oh my god dude she seems to be like
wealth nepo too I mean how can you speak
like this if you're not full-blown
neppo yeah stop stop so
um you guys like I don't like to like I
don't okay so there's I think it's like
publicly
funded no it's either publicly or
privately funded like these after school
or adult it's like adult groups right
where
God run by the state or it's run
privately I don't know all right thank
you to uh
hrh Collective who Maybe comedian but
probably is being serious I'm really I
had no idea yeah let's see what the
comments
are I currently work in a group home for
disabled and they do the opposite of
depress me they light up my day they're
so sweet they don't view the world in
the way most people do typically right I
feel that they can genuinely be happier
than us normies there's no need to be
depressed or awkward when seeing them
out and about well that's a very
measured very good point um wow if old
people walking for exercise and disabled
people using the ball for group
activities bother you so much you should
to really not go to the mall anymore
exactly most malls allow people to walk
for exercise as a community support
system but it's usually done in the
early hours before the stores even open
oh I didn't know that you're telling me
there's just a there's like there's
hordes of roaming Elders in the mall
before the stores open there I there
there is a few there's probably a couple
you know my grandpa used to walk but
normal hours he wouldn't like show up
early I always see them early because
the point is but the mall is open or
closed it's closed it's just like uh the
department stores are open and so they
could walk around but like the the
smaller stores aren't yet oh cuz I
used to go to a gym that was in a mall
and I would always see the old people
walking around doing their doing this
whatever this is the they're power
walking power walking thing and there
was there a lot of them yeah I'd say
there's about six or seven and what time
was it uh it was like an hour before the
actual Mall opened so maybe like 9:00
okay not super duper early yeah the idea
of just hundreds of old people walking
around in the mall before opening there
I didn't know about that I mean listen
it's got
AC it's shaded mhm no I get it like my
grandpa lived in Vegas and he needed to
walk for exercise so it makes it made a
lot of sense to me girl you need anger
management badly seriously so it doesn't
seem like her commenters are on board
it's more seems like a morbid curiosity
thing she's definitely not joking even
based on the comments because they they
would be in on it if she was like if
this was her thing how are you about to
be a mother and you're collaborating
with a predator and judging disabled
people that could be your daughter oh
she's pregnant I don't know is she is
she collabing with uh James Charles yes
she is yeah they're talking about James
Charles yeah she did a Tik Tok with him
like last week oh shout out to James I
mean wow good is she big like she has a
lot of
followers I don't know I mean she was
popular on Tik Tok when I saw the meme
but I don't know if I don't know malls
are a relatively safe space for the
elderly and disabled people can go they
know the place and it's not totally
isolated from the rest of society a lot
of them don't get the chance to be
social or developed social skills
outside this group why they don't go
alone is because a lot of them might
feel nervous or judged but it's easier
when you have your support group and
there are those who understand firsthand
what you go through they eat there
entertain themselves and generally get
some exercise within the mall that's a
wonderful comment yeah wow I'm I'm
impressed with the uh with the measured
uh response by the commenters there very
good yeah all right let's do
Elon so we've got here it
is well I guess it's important to talk
about what led up to this which is he
went full anti-s semi oh and that's kind
of what leads into this interview we
never talked about this this was this
was nuts I think this is the tweet that
might actually ruin Twitter because
after he tweeted this like apple and
Disney and all these massive massive
corporations and Spenders just straight
up paused Okay and
like uh I think that's a lot of what
this conversation is going on about okay
here's what he wrote or did he erase it
he responded it's still there it's a
reply yeah it was a reply oh there yeah
he did leave it up
the C okay so it says to the cowards
hiding behind the anonymity of the
internet and posting Hitler was right
you got something you want to say why
don't you come say it to our faces then
this person responded and said okay
Jewish communities have been pushing the
exact kind of dialectic hatred against
whites that they claim to want people to
stop using against them that is like
psychotic highlevel
anti-Semitism this this notion that the
Jews are
uh the Jews are pushing some agenda
against the whites specifically the
white is really creepy I'm de
I'm deeply disinterested in giving the
tiniest now about Western Jewish
populations coming to the dis disturbing
realization that those hordes of
minorities that support flooding their
country don't exactly like them too much
you want truth set it to your face there
it is I mean this is the comment of like
a deeply bigoted Disturbed individual
yeah
and shout out to X 24,000 likes a large
part because of elon's response which
was absolutely he said you have said the
actual
truth I'm right can you believe that
no that kind of definitely crossed the
line I think where there was some amount
of plausible deniability you could give
him a pass but this is just straight up
like anti-semitic and like in the worst
way possible which is basically that the
Jewish conspiracy to
destroy white people's
country um golly that's a crazy response
right it's so crazy I I can't believe it
honestly so I'm like did he mean
something that I'm not understanding but
I don't know what could he meant by that
he says he clarified in the interview so
I want to find out what he clarified
here here he
said I guess his problem is with the ADL
the Anti-Defamation League which I think
is a Jewish advoc group mostly I think
and
so here this is what he said the ADL
unjustly taxs the majority of the West
despite the majority of the West
supporting the Jewish people in Israel
this is because they cannot by their own
tenants criticize the minority groups
were their primary threat it is not
right and needs to
stop they can't criticize the minority
the reason I I guess the context here is
that the ADL had condemned him yeah I
know he had trouble with that so he's
he's uh he's on the war path here right
I understand that if he's got criticism
of the ADL but this person was like yo
Jewish people are Jewish people
are like you
know yo dude we need to round up Jews
and then Elon Musk is like you have said
the actual truth my friend like a little
more information would have been
good and he keeps bitching that like the
Maj the the media didn't cover my uh
clarification it's like well it's not
really make it it
really better it's not really their job
to cover every single tweet you
make
um the ADL is leading anti-hate
organization in the world founded in
1913 its Timeless mission to stop the
defamation of the Jewish people and
secure Justice and treat fair treatment
to all today the ADL continues to fight
all forms of anti-Semitism and bias
using Innovation and Partnerships to
drive impact yeah I don't know a lot
about the ADL I know some people uh have
issues with
their politics or methods I don't know
but
um yeah someone says yes but this is not
fair to say truthful to say that Jewish
communities promote uh dialectic hatred
towards whites say what you want about
the ADL but don't generalize the Jewish
Community yeah I mean I don't even know
anything about the ADL so wait he didn't
even back it up he he said you you write
that this does not extend to all Jewish
but it is also not limited to the ADL
bro how is that okay you almost
clarified but then you did but and
you're bitching that the media didn't
cover this like you loser
so the all these media people they
dropped out they were doing like 300
million a year it was like the primary
source of income they are
and he says so in uh so much so
in the
interview
um
let's see Elon and another reply guess
here's more
clarification to give him the full uh
scope of his
comments he said and at the risk of
being repetitive I am deeply offended by
adl's messaging and any other groups who
push de facto anti-white racism or
anti-asian racism or racism of any kind
sick of it stop it now I don't know what
you're talking about I mean I don't know
about the ADL they're doing anti-white
racism I don't know probably
not I don't know seems kind of farfetch
but again I don't know anything about
him does the ADL do uh White racism you
guys fact check that no I have no idea
what he's talking about he he talks
about this more in his interview with
the times as well he tries to clarify as
well uh it's so funny to me after
reading this how his demand to be fairly
quoted really doesn't change what he
said so anyway he goes uh after all this
he got tons of backlash he went to
Israel I guess on an apology tour MH um
he arrived in Israel and Elon tweeted
actions speak louder than
words
yeah because he did an action I mean
he's saying that about himself yeah I'm
not sure about uh I don't think it works
like that yeah I don't think you can say
that to say that by
yourself yeah
pussyy kind of let other people draw
their conclusion he also met with prime
minister Benjamin Netanyahu Elon Tor an
Israeli village where dozens of people
were killed in the mahos the Hamas LED
October 7 of the attacks video of Elon
Musk and Netanyahu met with local
residents of the Kutz Kar Aza mhm let's
take a
look I mean chilling with Netanyahu who
even if you're like supportive of Israel
generally is not great I mean he
sucks he's like a psychotic freak am I
Jewish returned home not home yet but
returned to
Israel
most when the terrorists infiltrated
into
the what is wrong why is he walking like
a Frankenstein monster can I see it
again look at his arms the best
is when
teror
itself it looks like he's not really
there like mentally
well might be on to something there
based off of what we're about to watch
well actions speak louder than
words think he's listening to them okay
whatever so he went and did a propaganda
tour for Israel an apology for saying
Jews are trying to uh ruin white
people's Society so that's the leadup to
it um and now my
friends I don't have the link to the
interview is it down here it's further
up in the dock it's one of the first
stories okay sorry I can't open it on
Zach's computer for some reason what
number is it number one Andrew sorin
interviews Elon at the New York Times
deal book Summit I don't see there's no
number one I don't know what you mean by
that right under the Goof and Gaff
section at the top of the dock um number
one is New Angle of older man dancing
okay not in the Goofs and gaffs if you
go down one section Goofs and gaffs
under goof and he said under oh and I
don't know who the Andrew Ross
sorin is I am Jewish neither does Elon I
am
gay I am a Muslim all right so with that
being said this is an hour and a
half
long and
um well we'll watch as much as we can I
the first part is really good I don't
know if it stays as good for as long but
I guess we'll see so here it is Ela mus
on advertisements trust and the wild
storm in his mind I am disa here we go
should we get popcorn i' eat popcorn
right now
all right I'm going to skip all this
obviously blah blah blah yeah thank
you so much there's some time stamps in
the
dock um also he's wearing a necklace um
which was from the parents of one of the
uh hostages from October 7 and he's
wearing what he's wearing uh a necklace
that was given to him by one of the
parents okay one of the victims um and
he or sorry one of the hostages and he
said he's not not going to take it off
until they're returned and also he
claims that he made this uh PL to go to
Israel before he got canceled for being
anti-semitic I believe
[Music]
that I mean who knows what he was there
to talk about it could be
like him looking at business opportunity
all right so here it is let's play it
good evening everybody thank you so much
uh for being with us through out the day
uh and I couldn't be uh more pleased uh
to sit with Elon Musk as our final
interview of uh this remarkable uh time
we've all had uh together he doesn't
need much of an introduction but I want
want to say a couple things um he's
personl studies were yeah oh so it was a
soldier that's is that a dog tag that's
the tags that soldiers wear did they
update it is that like Hightech always
been like that oh I had one
too so anyway um uh indiv I'm going to
skip this whole intro
SpaceX he's
glazing call a visit as you all know so
well we discussed earlier um on Monday
to Israel where he met with the Prime
Minister there and the president of
Israel and we're going to talk about
everything and my hope is that we can
talk about how he thinks uh about his
influence about his power um about all
of it and we're going to talk about
Innovation and everything else um I want
to say just two other things real quick
we met each other for the first time 16
years ago yeah a long time it's been a
long time and all this kids were three
uh when when we first met um I don't I
think you just you're about to deliver
your first Roadster I don't think you
had yet paage was still waiting yeah I
don't know what that means all kids are
the same age which is so bizarre because
he has so many kids from different
people but he just yeah grew a bunch of
them and lab yeah like 2007 2007 2008 um
and I remember was delivered 2008 I
remember going back to The Newsroom and
saying I think I just met the next Steve
Jobs and um okay I'm going to hold to
that okay I'm going to hold to that but
a lot has happened uh oh between so now
he's here we go and it starts off in the
most uncomfortable this when I first met
you and now uh you came to deal book
it's been boring that's for sureit
actually technically I do have a boring
company bro you can't make that J 2012
you came to dealbook and sat on the
stage uh and we we're we're thrilled to
have you back con 2012 but there's been
so much that's happened between now he
said something about con 2012 didn't he
you remember that
what's that I what happened when we
were in Israel this guy went to
like Sudan or somewhere where they were
having like a really up Civil War
and they were were using child soldiers
and he did this big expose about how we
got to um res do something about it and
it went so viral like I think everybody
in the world saw this and the guy ended
up um was in Uganda thank you the guy
ended up
uh a week he was like in every news
place he was like blowing the up
and then like yeah after a few days or a
week he was outside jerking off on the
corner of a street
and then then basically that was the end
of the story that was the end of con
2012 wow coming with that
heat coming with that
jizz yeah he's just be he's just beating
off at a intersection what the
hell yeah pretty interesting stuff let's
not talk about and then and there's been
so much that's happened in the past week
week and a half and a lot of folks and I
want to tell you this a lot of folks uh
called me up and said you really you
really going to host Elon Musk here can
you believe what he just said on on
Twitter um on X on x I'm going to say
this it's clear that he was getting lots
of push back and pressure from people
being like do not have him on MH
so the tone of this is pretty explicitly
like a call out I feel like that's the
only reason I no idea what this Twitter
thing keep talking about should you
platform him that's what they said yeah
should you platform him and I said that
I think that it's our role and I know
you have issues with journalist I have a
platform um I know you have an issue
with journalists often times but I said
it's our role to have conversations and
to inquire and um to sometimes even
interrogate ideas and that's I'm hoping
we can do that so I want to start just
so we can begin this conversation and
just level set take us through
everything that happened if you could
everything no over the past week and a
half how long have you got we we're
gonna we've got the time uh
okay you you send out a you send out a a
post or an X or a tweet I know
whatever um I'm trying to change like
when things were just 140 characters it
made sense to call him a tweet because
like a bunch of little bats Ching but
when you know point in which you can put
like 3our videos on it's like it's a
very long tweet he like trying to talk
about the anti-semitic can we just
get there he's like but don't call itwi
he's trying to derail it so hard and um
don't call it Twitter it's already so
uncomfortable their interaction I don't
know why there's just this really tense
yeah uh Vibe between them so so here we
are post is more descriptive I think and
at some point I don't know where you
were but you write in responding to
another tweet yes um this is the actual
trth truth and it set off a firestorm of
criticism all the way to the White House
right oh Biden said some about it
oh he's this trip to Israel you
have advertisers who left the platform
people call well the the trip to Israel
is independent of of it wasn't something
like a apology to her want to be clear
that was let's talk about that so just
but there's no way that's true I I mean
I can believe it because a trip to
Israel is something you kind of need to
plan a little bit it's like so far not
for him maybe not for if he's in deep
he's trying to make a gesture that
dude just gets on it he owns a plane
like in his back but he has a lot of
business there they have Tesla there
that's true Tesla is actually pretty big
and becoming really big in becoming big
yeah okay maybe maybe there's a chance
that I I all I'm saying is that that
could be true could be true sure okay
yeah it's worth saying you're right take
us back to the moment at which you write
that trip Israel is independa of it
wasn't like in response to that at all
well let's do we'll do Israel in just a
moment and I I I have no problem being
hated by the way nobody nobody asked if
y you do you do yeah no one think
evidence shows otherwise no one has a
bigger problem oh I didn't know
there was clips of it here he is what
yeah yeah that's con how come thank you
oh thank you girl yo we got popcorn for
this this is good pop going
yeah no oh oh Goda best I didn't
mean to open that I push space bar
that's
it why is sandwich is there Lord
there oh sandwich Subway sandwich what
do you mean you think about bread you
want a sandwich you think of bread are
you are you trying to um mind control me
into buying you a sandwich what
what what what you guys want you guys
want
sandwiches I mean you want a sandwich I
mean you want I know such a thing going
on you guys I'm not sure I know what
you're suggesting there but like if you
are offering to get a sandwich all I eat
is sandwich yeah sandwich sounds good
speaking of sandwich I don't hate the
idea H yeah we should get Uncle pully's
that place was really good if you guys
are down if you want other stuff it
sounds like a lot of meat yeah yeah I
knew it oh no no no I got a a uh caprisi
over there that was really good it was
like an artichoke capr that's why you
wanted
dude it was good that's made for you it
was very good pesto Capra and arter
choke
perfect thank you con thank you
con did you guys fix your um little ad
you guys
made oh yeah we need to oh it's on
Twitter speaking of not missing the the
business expensed
sandwiches we gotta watch that whole
thing
um the sandwich place is closed Uncle
paie it is
closed paie Paulie Paulie what are you
doing but I will find another
one very good just as good while Le
recommended me that place it was
freaking super good nice all right we'll
find another spot go ahead El
stop I hear you
away well but you know what let's go
straight to that then for a second sure
because there is an idea and you could
say that I think it's a real weakness to
one to be liked a real weakness I I do
not this man he won't let get to the
point God he's like trying to derail it
so bad this then there's a difference
between saying I don't care if anyone
likes me or they hate me but given your
power and given what you have amassed
and your the importance you have
I would think you want to be trusted I
would think maybe you don't need to be
liked or hated but trusted matters if if
x is going to become a financial
platform where people going to put their
money where people where it's a great
Point Yeahs government's going to give
you money for for uh for Rockets where
people are going to get into the cars
they need to ultimately decide that you
are they don't have to say that they
they love you but that you are
ultimately a decent and good good human
being yes I mean I I I think I am um but
I'm certainly not going to uh do some
sort of tap dance to prove to people
that I am um so okay if the tap dance is
not saying anti-semitic yeah that's
not they're not asking much a low bar
yeah it's a really low bar dude I think
the question alone was already showing
how far off musk is from where he should
be like the way he's
thinking Grandpa's feeling he shouldn't
even be talking about whether people
hate him or love him or whatever it is
he should R he should rise above all
that yeah
yeah trust I mean I think we break that
down in a few ways uh if you I think
part of the reason why so many people do
like him is that he is very much like a
real person hi if you think of other of
the richest people like Bill Gates and
Warren Buffett or whoever else you don't
like he really is putting himself out
there for Worse definitely learning why
the others don't not to take credit
where it is due he did achieve a lot so
people also love him for that yeah but
as a cold personality I think a lot has
to do with just the fact that he's
willing to post nine gag memes on his
Twitter account you know but yeah just
don't put Jews hate in there
man if you want satellites sent to Orit
reliably uh SpaceX will do 80% of all
master orbit this year China will do 12%
the rest of the world will do eight that
includes boing lock heat and everyone
else so the track record of the rocket
uh is the best by far of anything you
you could you could hate my guts next
you could not trust me it is relevant
the rocket track record speaks for
itself uh with respect to Tesla we make
the best no I I want to trust you
because like he has huge government
contracts he has so much influence to do
makes their he calls the shots yeah
makes the decision absolutely all of it
you know just because your business is
doing
well you
know still need to know a weird Point
yeah cars whether you height your hate
me like me are are indifferent uh do you
want the best car or do you not want the
best car question so uh uh well there so
I will certain on P and Jonathan like
the only reason here this is the this
part's crazy the need to trust him does
come into play because even I was a fan
of the car until I learned more about
him and I also learned that the car is
not as safe as they promoted to be
that's true there's Auto Drive which is
not it's not auto drive he was
definitely deceptive they were as
deceptive in the way they marketed that
for sure and it's it's him the team that
works on the car doesn't agree with him
but he's the one making the calls and
the fake promise and all this
right all right this part's
crazy so I will certainly not Pander and
Jonathan like the only reason I'm here
is because you are a
friend like what was my speaking fee you
you're not making any first of all I'm
Andrew uh yeah sorry it's okay he got
the name
wrong he says after he said I'm here cuz
I'm your friend he said I'm only here
because I'm your friend I wouldn't do
this other
cuz so so you know what I mean like and
then he goes yo that's not even my name
dude from this part it's so off the
rails I feel like it just gets so tense
after this it's because you are a
friend like what was my speaking fee you
you're not making any is that why the
richest man in the world does public
speaking events for a feet no he's
trying to make the point that he doesn't
take a fee that he's of course he
doesn't why would he what would be
significant fee for somebody that
already that that much money the worest
man in the world what he's there is he
wants publicity he wants press he wants
right right brand awareness he wants
video clips with him online it's very
much to his benefit to do that that I
was say he want to say look at my
necklace I'm not
anti-semitic
true very true hey first of all I'm
Andrew but uh yeah sorry it's okay dud
that is soar we've known each other for
a very long time you're smoking um it I
mean it doesn't get more embarrassing
than that oh he said it's
smoking what does that mean is high uh
second of all we've known each other for
a very long time misspoken um misspoken
oh misspoken yeah someone on that stage
is very high though I'll tell you that
right
now and not
on he he's he knows he's like oh
I'm going to look like a giant jackass
and there's nothing I can do about it
now
listen you
know uh what I'm trying to illustrate is
that sometimes I say the wrong
thing I think there are a lot of people
who are tired but let let me go
back no you should hear the sketches
that SNL wouldn't post by the way those
are really
good um what and I would say
unfortunately this journalist doesn't
want to do banter with him at all giving
you chest pain look it is so
uncomfortable banther is like a
5-year-old sense of humor well he's
trying to ask him something serious and
he won't he's been trying for like five
minutes w't let him finish this question
fortunately or unfortunately whatever
friendship we have not great we don't
talk to each other that that much but
let me and then he's you know what he
was thinking he's like hold on I don't
want people to think that we're friends
yeah he's like uh we don't talk that
much dude I don't our friendship is not
that good for the record or fortunately
or unfortunately whatever friendship we
not great we don't talk to each other
that that much but let
me
god this is so this is the worst thing
ever New York Times baby let me ask you
this it's true that's true where am
IES the point is I'm I'm here because
you're you're a friend not because uh
I'm get paid or because I need any
validation or anything the the is that
we've been friends for 16 years um and I
promised you I'd be here and that's why
I'm here I appreciate you being here
reason but let me ask you this this then
go go at it just tell me what happened
you you write this tweet that says that
this is the actual truth people read
that tweet yes and they say Elon Musk is
an anti-semite that he he he he is he is
riling up this base you're hearing it
from uh as I said the White House you're
hearing it from Jewish groups all over
um I think Jonathan greenblat from the
ADL was here um there's there's lots of
people who say not the ADL and by the
way it's not just that did you read the
whole thing I did and that's what I want
to ask responses excuse me I said
more more responsive yeah I said more I
said more than what you just read was
God damn it
again since when does space open imag it
wasn't um and I'm an American Jew about
come on man God damn it you know and I'm
glad that we all just read the
supplemental information that somehow
absolves him so much it's so dumb um it
wasn't just the people who who had the
that view it was actually people who H
who really are anti-semites who said oh
my
goodness go go Elon this is fabulous
people have been and that actually was
the thing that really uh really set me
back and I said to myself what's going
on here and I want to know how you felt
about that in that moment when you when
you saw all of this
happening yeah um well first of all I I
did clarify God damn it
almost immediately what I meant I would
say that that was um you know if I could
go back and say I should in retrospect
um not have replied to that particular
person um and I should have uh written
in Greater length what the what is this
story are you high bro I did
subsequently clarified in replies uh but
those clarifications were ignored by the
media um and essentially I handed a
loaded gun to those who hate me um and
arguably to those who hadti IC uh to and
for that I'm quite sorry that that is
not that was not my intention um so I I
did you know uh post on my primary
timeline to be Absol clear that I'm not
antii you're the CEO you can't post oh
he said he's not anti-semitic but yeah
oh well case closed on my primary
timeline to be absolutely clear on his
primary timeline even dude and that I in
fact I'm philosemitic and the trip to
Israel was planned before any of that
you hear him say that he's
philosemitic did he say that already
yeah hold on I hate when people
absolutely clear that I'm not
anti-semitic um and that I in fact if
anything am philosemitic so what is that
I think he means he loves Jews which is
also creepy right it's like the Trish
right right right yeah it's like listen
I don't want you to hate me or to love
neutral neutral yeah we like neutral I
bad vibes I love Jew
all
right um and the trip to Israel was
planned before any of that happened uh
it was neither here or there do you see
you see this thing M you know what it is
I do because I actually followed your
entire trip to Israel right why don't
you tell
everybody this is this
says says bring them home it's in Hebrew
by the way he's looking for the
letters
it's got to be the
hostages it was given to me by the
parents of of one of the
hostages Mike I said I would wear it as
long as there was a hostage store
remaining and I
have um bro you wore that
necklace that's okay and all and I'm I'm
glad but also just answer the question
about your dumb comment right still kind
of dancing around it don't bring out the
puppy and make us theide because yeah he
did a decent apology but it's the way he
goes on about it cuz he said listen that
was a super dumb uh and I'm and I may
have handed a gun to to anti-semites
that want to use me as a mouie no he
said that he handed a loaded gun to his
hater and then he said and arguably
to anti-semitic as
well sure but you know it's like it it
keeps going off the rails yeah I
mean it's still up just erase it bro why
is it still up that's true that's
crazy what was that trip like and
obviously you know that there's a public
perception that and and you're
clarifying this
now um but there's a public perception
that that was part of a apology tour if
you will that this had been said online
there was all of the criticism there was
advertisers leaving we talked Bob IG
hope they stop you hope don't advertise
he's talking to Bob Iger the CEO of
Disney okay now he loses his
here leaving we talked to bober I
hope they stop you hope don't advertise
you don't want them to advertise no what
do you
mean if somebody's going to try to
Blackmail me with advertising blackmail
me with money how is it blackmail how
yeah that's what I was confused how is
it blackmail how is it blackmail I mean
you put your statement out there by
yourself is any accountability blackmail
I mean that's like being like yo why are
you my my son being like why you
blackmailing me to eat dinner with
dessert
yeah why are the police why the police
blackmailing me with this arrest for for
murdering my threatening to put me in
jail right now this
blackmail
um yeah hey Twitter world this is yours
Tru I mean it's just accountability man
you did something something and
something happened cause and effect baby
Isaac
Newton
but go
yourself is that clear the reporter is
dumbfounded here in the audience well
well let me ask you here in the
audience that's how I feel don't
advertise
youe
yeah speechless I mean I mean who said
don't stop advertising please I hope you
stop advertising about the economics of
of x if if if if part of the underlying
model at least today and maybe it needs
to shift maybe the answer is it needs to
shift away from
advertising um if if you believe that
this is the one part of your business
where you will be beholden to those who
uh have this
view what do you do uh
why
yourself bro that's he's not engaging at
all he's just having a straight up
meltdown and by the way oh can you link
me that Russell Brand
yeah it's so
embarrassing I sure
care
right yes no no Linda Yaro is right here
and she's got to sell advertising
absolutely so um no no tell so so
no
Jesus I mean
my Torah portion was less awkward
than this thank you little juice nice
thanks everybody absolutely so um no no
so
no is is is going to do it's going to
kill the company he says it's going to
kill the company you will he says Apple
dude okay okay you already did we got to
watch this we got to watch this un
unpaused advertising boycott is uh is is
going to do it's going to kill the
company no and do you think that the I
but and the whole world but don't will
know that those advertisers killed the
company and we will document it in great
detail saying to that sounds like
blackmail he saying to all my Fanboys go
harass Disney and dud that's blackmail
if you pull your we are going to detail
everything in great what what's the
what's the document he's going to write
a fat Tome dude he's going to he's going
to write all of this in his um what was
it called when uh when girls pass around
a book where they talk burn book or
uh not burnbook there was another term
for it it wasn't burn maybe burnbook
sure burnbook was a mean girl I never
heard of that you don't remember that no
I've never heard of that oh man oh in
Mean Girls there's this thing called the
burn book where they put photos of
people in their high school and like
write horrible nasty and then in
the movie someone prints them out and
like puts them all over the scho does
that happen in real life um not in my
experience but they just have Twitter
now so yeah slam book that was the term
I was looking for but when he says
people around the world are going to
know that it was you Bob Iger yeah I
think Bob's a Jewish too I think is he
maybe he's not I don't know I'll look it
up but um who do you think he's talking
about that's going to rise up yes he is
oh he's the Fanboys exactly who are The
Fanboys these
days gper weirdo PR Bo Nazis
basically yeah
essentially stand back and
standby he knows that he up and
he's trying to make himself a martyr for
free speech totally yeah and also it's
like Twitter is already dead you already
did that it's not going to be because of
Disney right you already did that he
bought it for like 55 billion and it's
now already it's been valued recently at
like 20 so he's already lost 35 billion
and I'm pretty and I'm pretty sure that
it's not long for this world especially
after this I think it's actually going
to there's so many people that actually
used to love Twitter and they're like
they're pissed now yeah I used to love
Twitter cuz there isn't yet something
else right now instead of well I'll tell
you what real has been pretty fire for
me lately
yeah but that's different oh that's
different that's different I don't know
that we need Twitter I think the world
will be fine without it Instagram and
Tik Tok the best way to meet girls like
like I genuinely I genuinely think that
people are going to be fine yeah you can
post I've been fine I deleted the app a
long time ago and I'm totally fine like
if there's something I want to say I'll
do it in insta stories there you go yeah
you know and you're going to go to bed
and you're still going to be a
loser Olivia you just have like a
standup routine basically in your draft
you just need to take it on the road at
this point anytime I have a thought and
I'm like damn I wish if someone was here
right now I just throw it in there and
then I return to it and if it still
makes me laugh then I I let it go so
there's a filter it's not you're not
letting the intrusive thoughts win right
away right the intrusive thoughts make
their way somewhere though yeah so no uh
cookies for you
[Music]
um yeah I think if if Twitter went under
people would just go to threads and I
don't think anyone would give a I
really don't I think the world would
move on very very
quickly but there are those advertisers
I imagine are going to say they're going
to say we didn't kill the company oh
yeah they're going to say tell to tell
to Earth tell they're going to say
they're going to say this man is so
delusional he thinks all of
Earth is rooting for X not Twitter
Twitter is so uh fundamental that it
undermines the whole entire Earth the
future of all living things on this
planet are in question
now that you killed the company because
you said these things and that they were
inappropriate things and they didn't
feel comfortable on the platform right
that's that's what going say and let's
see how Earth responds to that what do
you mean you know you know what the
problem is though okay this then this
goes back to we'll both make our what do
you even say to that iess I guess I
would asked well what do you mean Earth
it's definitely not me cuz it would be
interesting for him to unpack that what
the do you mean
Earth cases right and we'll see what the
outcome is what are the economics of
that for you I mean you you have
enormous resources so you can actually
keep this company going for a very long
time would you keep it going for a long
time if there was no
advertising I mean if the company fails
because of AD advertis boycott it will
fail because of an advertised boycott
and that will be what bankrupted the
company and that's what all everybody
Earth will know luring the out of
his speech right there everybody on
Earth I'm telling you this guy is
blasted right here I don't think so I
think he's just super embarrassed I
think he probably is cuz all these guys
are like into like micro smoing yeah no
I think he he's tweaking hard mushro in
order to he but he he has kind of a
speech impediment thing like he's always
he always did here let me go back to
where
literally because of an ad advertised
boycott it will fail because of an
advertised boycott and that will be what
bankrupt the company and that's what all
everybody on Earth will
know what do you think then of
the trust though then it'll be gone and
it'll be gone because of an advertised
boycott but but you recognize that some
of those people are going to say that
they didn't feel comfortable on the
platform and I I wonder I just wonder
and ask you and think about that for a
second tell to the judge what there's no
judge this is like the um this is the
same response as uh what's the clip that
we recently watched in our Podcast chat
about was it Matt R where he's like I
did a little mistake and she reacted oh
that TI to made it way worse I'm going
through a breakup right now we were in
love and I made one tiny tiny little
mistake and then she turned it into a
huge thing the way she responded just
ruined the whole thing yeah not my
little mistake that's bad vibes for sure
this gives me the same vibe right I made
one little it's not my up to ruin
the whole thing it's the way they
reacted to my up by the way they've
been the fact that they're still on X I
think proves that there's been a fair
bit of effort to make it work because
this isn't the first time that
right he's done something like this
although it might be the most egregious
and
blatant but but the judge is going to be
the judge is the
public oh okay and you think that the
public is going to say that that Disney
is making a
mistake yeah and they're going to boycot
Disney okay delusional I think he's over
it I think he thought he was coming to a
friendly interview they may have even
talked beforehand said let's not talk
about this I don't know no way you don't
think so no it's just not going well for
him and New York Times they wouldn't do
something like dirty yeah I guess very
yeah very professional but the the
interviewer is being he's not being
combative but he's definitely
challenging him probably more than he
wanted a lot more than he
wanted there already are well there
there are some that are for for for lots
of different reasons but you think that
this is going to that you have the this
goes to actually the interesting of a p
of of power and leverage let the chips
fall where they may all right Lex Luther
they Superman will never find my hidden
layer ask what why that is the approach
and I ask if because you've been apprach
well you've been very particular about
the I mean the approach to Tesla uh you
think about the engineering involved in
that the approach to SpaceX the approach
to um some of the stuff you're doing
with with AI has been very specific
right there's not a let let the CH we
haven't even talked about his AI yet on
the show have we have you been following
that at all no he started doing it on
like apes right no no no that's the
that's the chip brain chip I'm talking
about his like chat GPT oh no you know
about this
to gr it's called like groon or
something and it it's it's chat imagine
if chat
gbt if its answers were a little bit
worse and also written by the most
annoying person on Reddit oh my God it's
like epic M Marino bacon Walt narwhal
like being thrown at you it's real
bad I'll find you an example I'll show
you when God if he wasn't just doing
like anti-Semitism World Tour the people
on the right would despise him
for being
cringe approach to those businesses I
don't think no we focus on making the
best products and and and taes has
gotten to where it's gotten with no
advertising at all yeah but you're
selling a product you're not a social
media platform like what I understand
that also you're talking about buying
sponsors versus selling
them Tesla currently sells I thought
he's supposed to be smart I just don't
understand he is supposed to be his
answers are so stupid yeah I wonder I
wonder at what point it starts to hurt
all of his other businesses or if that
point will ever come I don't know from
what I understand the
uh the Space X and the
[Music]
um uh what's the internet one called
starlink the starlink is giving them
like an an insane Monopoly over space uh
cargo transporting yeah and like uh
satellite internet yeah to a dangerous
degree like where the government is like
super dependent on him for doing
twice as much uh in terms of
electric vehicles as the rest of
electric car makers and United States
combined Tesla has done more to help the
environment than uh all other companies
combined would be fair to say that
therefore as a leader of the company
I've done well for the environment than
everyone I'm the man I did that
that's all say human on earth yeah how
do you feel about
that feel about that yeah no I'm I'm
asking you personally how you feel about
that because this goes we're talking
about power and influence and I'm saying
I'm saying what what I care about is the
the reality of goodness not the
perception of it and what I see all over
the place is people who care about
looking good while doing evil them
okay all right let me ask you this
because I think part of this by the way
there's some people who said look this
repor to begin with has just created
problems that you created so many
amazing things that are changing our
world and and and I know you want to uh
make X this fabulous town you guys
enjoying this or should we do Matt R I
feel like we got it you want to keep
watching oh brother I I can watch this
at home you guys feeling Matt rif Jordan
yeah let's do it I'm telling you you
guys are going to love this it's going
to be so much fun yeah we can watch this
at home
later holy holy balls
balls
um let's
see we're looking
for
where's the Matt R Jordan one oh it was
sent in Discord here let me grab it
oh I wanted to show this first um
Russell Brand disgraced comedian who's
now in a criminal investigation for
award
uh look at this response I mean oh my
God 50,000 likes now we all just watched
that so you know is this the
anti-establishment rallying cry that
we've been waiting for right here you've
already seen this moment we're going to
be talking about it on the show today
go
yourself is that clear
anti-establishment I hope it is oh my
God hey B here in the audience well well
let me ask you then so sort of a relief
to hear it was it kind of a kaaris for
you to hear that right in the heart of
the establishment at a New York Times
sponsored event go f yourself is this
what we've been waiting for is this what
we need does this mean now that the Free
Speech movement and the independent
political thought movement will take off
that there will be room room for
oppositional speech that there will be
room for a genuine counter establishment
movement join us on Rumble at these
talking about the richest man in the
world is this the anti-establishment
idiot dude I can't handle it yeah I
mean the richest man in the world whose
entire career is built off of Government
subsidies and contracts it could not be
more establishment my dude could not be
more but also so there's that BL blaring
uh
ignoramus I mean yeah he is the
establishment and so the other thing is
like is this what we've been waiting for
like he's the Messiah or some
what's been stopping you from saying
whatever you want nothing clearly that's
why he's on Rumble he's
stupid you know like we've been waiting
for
this what is this exactly going to do
for you though I don't know I don't
understand but this this is what they do
how they protect their own this man just
had a meltdown
publicly and they'll look at that and
just enable them and be like yo this
guy's a
messiah this guy's Gonna Save Us All by
telling Bob Iger to off because he
didn't want to advertise on
Twitter that's the moment we've all been
waiting for you know what the moment I'm
waiting for it's for you to go to jail
Russell Brand you
Tick Tock that's the moment I'm
waiting for freak is coming dude his
downfall has been nuts to
watch so that was fun I thought that was
silly yeah people love it I mean 50,000
likes that's crazy it is crazy but I
mean that is the crowd the people on
that are still on Twitter speaking of
which um so Jordan Peterson the great
thinker the great thinker so campaign
and campaign and
research has Matt rifon who is being
cancelled he's being cancelled for being
a comedian my God that comedians being
cancelled no how could this
happen how is it being cancelled when
the special is on Netflix the biggest
platform it's just lost all the
cancelling thing is just it just means
people were mad at you yeah people were
criticizing you that's all it means now
it's quite something who cares what you
believe anyway here here's Jordan
sucking off Matt R for being brave it's
a modern twists on an old joke you know
what I mean it it was a real
circumstance that happened an
exaggerated instance that really
happened and I went you know this is
this is a classic joke why not give my
own personal modern Twist on it and move
on the joke's like a minute and 30
seconds of people were like all he did
was bash women and I purposely did it
first in the show to go hey just so you
know this is this is the kind of humor I
like to tell and if it's not for you you
are so more than welcome to turn off the
TV right now
yeah okay dude is this the most
pretentious F show
ever master class with Jordan Peterson e
the
master crazy
huh hello everyone I had the opportunity
today to welcome and speak with one of
the world's most outstanding current
comedians yes young guy 28 years old
Matt re who's exploded onto the comedy
scene in the last few years right after
having put his time in the trenches he's
been working as a comedian in small
clubs and so forth he started when he
was 15 so he put in his 10 years before
really becoming popular he's been the
subject of a relatively dedicated
Council campaign in recent weeks and so
we had a chance to discuss that to
discuss his witty fast Brave bra and uh
appropriate response to that
cancellation to talk about that sort of
thing it was so appropriate not R is so
bra more detail he is the bravest some
say the bravest yeah some would I would
and also to detail out um his the the
structure of his new tour and his plans
for the future all stop glazing planning
this opening which I don't usually do
because I like to do things
spontaneously but but I H I have to get
this one right okay so you got to help
me get this straight okay okay so now
you're a comedian and you got cancelled
for a domestic assault joke
and then in response to that instead of
apologizing like a good boy you put up a
joke ad site about special needs helmets
to protect the people who are offended
by you and now got them to get yourself
out of trouble you're going to come on
my podcast I never true that that
actually is a a fairly good
point I don't know if he understands the
the context of coming on here or what I
was hoping it would make things way
worse I'm hoping we can drive sales to
that very real website about the helmets
yes anyways congratulations on that I
thought I thought the joke was funny
risky and funny and I thought your
response was dead on like one of the
things I've noticed dude the way that he
goes it's just a Twist on an old-timey
joke that I wanted to put my own spin on
it was it was
like if she uh could cook she wouldn't
have that black eye right what's the
twist I mean it's just not funny that's
all yeah the most simplistic joke
laughing at a woman who was hit by her
partner a horrible uh and by the way the
joke is
that it was not good it was not a good
joke iry I don't know if I'm like not up
to date but what is the cancellation
campaign included so far I wish they
would say just people being upset yeah
that's it cuz I mean that's also Free
Speech just like him telling his joke
true well like you said he's still on
Netflix
um I can't I don't think he's been
blacklisted anywhere or anything like
that that I've
heard that people who are harassed by
sensorial minded null wits almost always
back down and apologize and then my my
sense of that is that a mob comes after
them first for whatever hypothetical sin
they've committed never
apologize it's the conservative way
never admit you're wrong never change if
you change you're a hypocrite don't ever
change your mind bucko you'll expose
yourself and then they apologize I
believe the same things I did as when I
was 15 that's
consistency
yes and a second mob comes after them
for that exactly and then they lessen
their own character by the false apology
has not let him say he just want
shut the up you some master
class they embolden these idiot accusers
and so why did you decide when when this
blew up around you and I mean in some
ways it's a tempest in a teapot but when
this I never heard that before it's a
tempest in a teapot I like that what is
that does that mean a tempest is a giant
storm I know what a tempest is but what
is Tempest in a teapot it's too much in
a in a cuz it could be that it's like
maybe it's personal no it just means
it's blown out of proportion or but it's
just in a
teapot he's downplaying it essentially
The Tempest in a teapot is also phrased
as storm in a teacup or Tempest in the
teacup an idiom meaning a small event
that has been exaggerated out of
proportion really that's my because the
Tempest in the teacup it it does not
endanger anybody there's not enough
liquid in it to do any significant Dam
Dam it right yes so like you know how
bad could a tempest in a teapot or
teacup as it were be dude thank
you blew up around blew up around you
and I mean in some ways it's a tempest
in a teot but when this grew up around
you why did you decide to take the
strategy that you took why weren't you
like racked with guilt and apologetic
and why weren't you being a little
because it's just comedy I'm just
doing what's funny to me it's never but
then like can't you just say people are
and people are just reacting to how they
react you know like we're all just doing
our human yeah so so like by the
same logic you want people to leave you
alone because you're just doing comedy
you're just being you and that's fine
but then you also have to appreciate
that people are going to get mad and
they're just going to do their thing too
people going to people yeah and I'm sure
he knew that joke is going to be on the
right on the line of like you know okay
not okay yeah I'm sure he knew that so
oh yeah I mean because he followed it up
with I'm just seeing how fun you guys
are tonight
yeah any deeper than that nor should it
be for anybody I'm saying things that my
imagination drums up that makes me happy
reliefs endorphins in my head that makes
my life happier and all I do is share
those thoughts with other people in
hopes that it makes their life easier
comedians are so important I
mean I just can't get over the the genre
of comedians they are basically the
Aristotle The Playdoh yeah of today no I
just do it for the
people who's that one uh Roman Emperor
who everybody loves oh who wrote
Reflections is it Augustus
or who wrote Reflections you think of
Marcus aurelus yeah Marcus aurelus dude
they are the modern day Vanguard
and we should all bow actually if you
see a standup comedian coming down the
street it is your obligation to bend the
knee and lower your head in reverence
for these Great Men all right what rules
you sons of what
rules well i' I've been watching what
you do on your specials and you you're
continually interacting with the
audience which and correct me if I've
got this wrong I mean a lot of the
comedians that I've spoken to they spend
a lot of time preparing their sets
practicing but you're doing it's it's it
seems to be something that's much more
akin to spontaneous wit is he just
talking about yeah isn't that typical
comedian that's literally called crowd
work every comedian does it and and by
the way he his his special was not crowd
work it was all
rehearsed uh and written it wasn't like
you know off the Dome no course not not
at all and that's a dangerous thing to
do because you could easily be not funny
oh high risk High reward yeah well and
it's also that because you're doing that
you don't have a lot of time to exactly
think through what you're going to say
right I mean if something strikes you as
amusing you pretty much have to go for
it and not for a Netflix special
comedians will practice that a whole
year long before they shoot their
special that's the whole point of the
special and the joke you got cancelled
for was not crowd work none of it was
Netflix let it air so it didn't get
cancelled you know yeah and now he's on
a podcast with 1.3 million views yeah
the thing is he's being silenced
iation I don't think it's a big deal I
don't I don't I just it's a dumb joke
it's stupid it's hacky I don't care
about it I don't really care about it
it's just like H all I know is that I
put it on and I turned it off after five
minutes I was just like H cuz the thing
is his stick was different and then he
put does this special and he's like hey
I'm a Joe Rogan comedian now boy hey I
kind of feel like he thinks that
everyone saw that and they were like
what a damaging damaging joke it's like
we watched it and we thought oh this guy
isn't like I thought he was Maybe funny
he's not though that's what it was
that's what it was for me too there was
a lot of the dialogue was just people
being like oh he's not actually
funny yeah you
know because if you're just cutting
crowd work from your hours and hours of
onset uh on stage and posting those
those W moments to Tik Tok right a big
difference than getting in front of a
camera for an hour straight and that's
really trying to prove your worth there
as a standup comedian like that was a
written joke right but in the end was it
was I wonder how much of this whole
narrative was built up by these people
who are like um running to to put their
jacket over the puddle for him or I
don't know like these conservatives on
daily wire who every time anyone gets
mad at anything they have to
yeah they have to throw themselves at
their feet so I do wonder how much was
like actual like people being mad and
how much was it like this kind of
amplifying I I think I can
guess if it was really a problem then
you would see like Netflix removing it
or something I don't know it's clearly
not on that
level yeah your head's full of
censorship related thoughts you're going
to be not funny in about 15 seconds so
you have to let the intrusive thoughts
win in comedy you have to so that's my
that's where I took cross with I was
listening I was like that has not been
good advice for me
brother that is in fact the only reason
pretty much in the past five years that
I've ever gotten cancelled or
whatever can let me tell you about the
button yeah child yeah this this is my
intrusive thought net
it's a wonderful
thing uh but no I don't I actually don't
even believe that's true like I mean
yeah you need to filter it out you need
to refine it a little bit there buddy
you need a button you need a button
bucko I really comes if you're an natur
funny person the first thing that comes
to your mind should be the funniest
thing to you most of the time Comm sit
it has to be the first thing yeah to
shut the you're such a bad
interviewer like I get that every you
think everybody wants to sit and listen
to every word you have to say but when
you have guests Jordan you have to let
them talk it's not about you
man so
ridiculous if you're writing a multiple
choice test if you could do if you could
catalog of this five minutes how much
time Jordan spent talking versus Matt
yeah it's got to be like 95% Jordan it's
a lot so far dude by the way you if you
second guess your your what your inition
self centered I mean you can even tell I
think that Matt's getting a little
weirded out by how much he's like just
listening to Jordan it's like you invite
me on your show to listen to you like
what the is happening and of course
the comments are so incredible
and Jordan kind of got glammed up I feel
like the whole thing is very
self-centered oh yeah did you see that
intro it looks like he has makeup or a
filter on and look at this this is the
oddest Most Beautiful Exchange these two
together are something I wouldn't have
guessed I'd enjoy as much as I have
wouldn't have guessed i' enjoy I saw one
praising him for bringing awareness to
those
helmets it's like one of the top
comments look at this look at this
sick of fantic Jordan Peterson
is such a comedian himself I am sorry
but even as like the biggest there he is
not funny so not funny he's very serious
he sucks the the joy out of anything
totally yeah he really makes me smile
his ability to blend a serious topic and
be playful around it is simply
remarkable
I couldn't feel any more like opposite
than that when I watch him that's what
it that's what this is this cult you
just crazy about the right answer you're
more likely to be wrong with the second
guess yeah true I wish my fans were
support me like that I'll do
like a horrible like take like say
something like horribly racist and dumb
and they'll be like dude he's honestly
just brave for doing that like I'm not
going to criticize him he's had a long
day he's Brave yeah you you could have
that you just need to run a cult you
know and like ban any things up anybody
that says slightly anything you're
talking to my you're talking to me it's
time to tighten things up here
baby that immediate response yeah that
immediate response tends to be better
yeah well and it's it's a weird thing CU
that thing that's comical inside you
dude he giving him no space to talk this
is his 41th episode and this man still
doesn't know how to shut the up
how do people watch this
driil horse dog providing you with
the intuition for the jokes it has to be
in I'm I'm just captivated by when he's
going to let Matt talk timing is
everything absolutely it has be quick
relationship with the audience yeah
timing is absolutely everything you want
to say the never heard that before
timing is everything insightful that's a
really insightful thing you guys hit on
the most pointed thing at exactly the
right time so what do you think or maybe
I don't know if you thought about it
what do you think so he does this he
asks him a question Matt answers in like
five words and then Jordan jumps in with
well you know that's real interesting
that you say that because uh my
grandmother once put her Pub rubbed it
across my face in a dream she had way
was exposed dim um Olivia do you think
there's a filter on Jordan or is it
makeup just make let me see I don't
think he's got a filter I think he he
certainly has a beauty filter and maybe
even for real he does there's a blur
there's like yeah you think so where's
my beauty filter oh my god let's get you
one wait can we do wait can we do Beauty
filters I just want to see what it's
like Olivia is a fashion I can we do
that I don't know what not like quickly
right now no not right now but I mean
like hypothetically I think that'd be
awesome yeah we could that'd be so
awesome I mean that new AI Tech is crazy
dude how it beautifies you you're ugly
ass how am I supposed to sit over here
when I'm looking at such beauty all
right so let's see let's see how he
handles this
question because well first of all how
broad scale do you think this Rebellion
against what you said actually is how
many people do you think are behind it
and why do you think it's become such a
big deal it's probably a few dozen
thousand which sounds like a lot until
you remember there's 8 billion people in
the world yeah but they're not okay
first of all eight billion ain't
watching your show brother let's just
chill out on that
you know 350 million in the US which is
a lot it's not 8 billion and I would say
90% of the small majority that is upset
with me doesn't go to comedy shows
anyway or wouldn't Vibe with me as a
person anyways which is fine they're
probably not that funny I watched a
couple of here he goes here he goes
started to hit a he hit a rhythm and
actually he was saying something that I
was interested to hear him say I'm
trying to make a point but let's see
where Jordan goes I'm sure this will add
a lot YouTube I can imagine oh my God
yeah I mean they're the sort of people
that you just want to what do you want
for them bro what you you are so bad say
it Jordan you are so bad the man
was cooking he was actually talking and
you interrupted him for this
I mean I have some EMP uh some
empathy because it's taken a long time
for me to get better at interviewing
people there's more than a bit and so I
I understand uh where he's coming from
but after 400 episodes man you got to
shut the
up you want for them you want them to
spend eternity in a Hell composed
nothing but people like them talking to
them so Twitter yeah yeah exactly that
but that's the thing is it's like
whether whether you enjoy what I do or
not you don't even have to know it
exists if I'm your problem if you and I
are face to face and you have a problem
with my comedy that I tell that I admit
to the world right
if you just remove yourself from me if
you do something as simple as just turn
around there is an entire planet behind
you you explore guess you have a special
on one of the biggest streaming platform
and it's on the homepage I clicked on it
without even one most popular so yes a
lot of people are going to see it if
they want or not and they're going to
have opinions he's not wrong also in the
sense that people you know I do think
people tend to get
too hysterical over things they can
ignore you know but I think it's also
like understanding they're just
expressing their opinion about it that's
yeah that too and I think everyone
should be okay with it yeah it's so I'm
curious about where this conversation
like what's the point what's the I was
about to say so what's the point of the
conversation it's like Matt R is
correctly saying like it's not really
that many people and it's not really
going to affect my career so you're not
being cancelled then not at all actually
far from so what what are we doing here
make drama yeah what is this
conversation about this it's about
Jordan it's about Jordan masturbating
for an hour yeah ex and letting Matt
talk for 13 minutes let's see the rest
of your life you don't ever have to
think about me you don't have to talk
about me I don't like scre heavy metal
music guess how often I think about it
or talk about it 0% of the time you just
remove yourself from the situation it's
a little it's not a Perfect Analogy
that's super unfair be because he built
a fan base came out with a big project
and then it alienated the fans that he
had so they are turning their backs I
that he is missing that aspect of it
that it's like it's not like he'd be
right in the sense if it's a bunch of
people that have never heard of him
before they saw that clip coming at him
but it's not it's his own fans that are
pretty pissed off about it so I I think
it it's like if I had like a ton of
Jewish fans and and I was beloved by the
Jewish community and I do my my first
standup and I'm like y'all heard I mean
that'll actually be funny y'all heard
about the Jewish car turns on a dime and
picks it
up got him but you know it might make
some people
uncomfortable you like that one hey you
know why Jews have big noses cuz air is
free oh I remember that one yeah I
remember that one I've heard all these
many
times yeah not very
funny I see no harm in trying to make
people laugh as a general um intention
yeah well I also don't don't
understanda from a purely logical
perspective what the people who are
complain laugh as a general um intention
I don't understand exactly from from a
purely logical perspective what the
people who are complaining exactly
expect from you because as and maybe it
is that they a have no sense of humor or
and and that's highly likely or that
they're doing something we can talk
about dude again you you Jordan you're
not listening everybody can have their
subjective experience they're not doing
anything that's the thing there's no
intention they're not doing there's no
cancellation they didn't like it right
and they complained about it that's it
man what the there's not more to
figure out we can wrap it
up problem solved you know let's see
getting some kind of benefit from their
from their from their complaints some
virtue signaling I really see that with
the men in particular well know I really
care a lot
women yeah I saw one Tik Tok video who
was like I I have a wife and I found
this severely disrespectful I was like
okay you cuck
whatever that word is so that word yikes
dude what the is this guy I hate
when people use that like unironically
it's like so embarrassing I thought even
like these people are embarrassed by it
now like it's like it's kind of fallen
out of the vernacular even of all these
right-wingers and again the dude is
allowed to have his
opinion you're like okay fine he doesn't
like my okay
play yeah what do you want to get
more outside of your wife like
chill out you're already married she
already respects you oh so you mean that
he's not doing it to get probably
if he's married
right cuz that's the only reason any man
would ever about yeah
what you yeah well I used to see I had
demonstrations around me which used to
be more common than they are now which
is just as well the worst people I ever
saw at those demonstrations weren't the
herodin women who were screeching like
fish wives but the men that were
hypothetically there to support them man
I tell you I couldn't even look at some
of those guys without having a shutter
run up my spine there's almost nothing
worse than a man who tries to worm
himself in with a group of women by
pretending to be more their side than
the women actually are when their actual
motivation is to use that what was that
g bro what are you going on
about I mean yeah what does this have to
do this conversation is
so ridiculous the fact that anybody
watch this and take away that it was
good 700,000 likes or views is nuts
man this is the rambling of a
unfocused cluttered
mind sad the evolutionary i' like to
hear Matt talk more olist who works at
Concordia he called that the sneaky
fire routine yeah yeah exactly well and
that's actually a phrase from
evolutionary biology I'll tell you a
funny story that goes along with that
this is got a story tell him a story
Jordan he's such a narcissist he thinks
nobody want people they want to hear me
talk let's be real what I'm have to say
is a lot more interesting than this
guest who's come here specifically for
this interview probably this one time
only let me tell you a story about my
grandmother and and so telling so
primatologists who studied
orangutans figured out a long time ago
that there are two very male types of
arut okay so there's like this is he's
in his he's in the bag right
here the evolutionary biology he
gets to talk about his lobsters and
buckets and talking about orangutan
ah he loves this tend to hang around in
trees they're Aral but the men the males
who become dominant in a given territory
get so large sort of like a linebacker
football and they have these big fat
pads around their face that are circular
they get so large they can't really go
in trees anymore and the females come to
them that's not a story but then there
are other males in what's the story I'll
tell you a story rambling about
orangutang what
storys hey do you know what a story is
Jordan stop I'm typing stop stop no more
stop vicinity for who the primatologists
thought were adolescent for a very long
time because they look like adolescent
males and they hang around in the trees
but they turn out to be many of them
fully M oops oops mature males whose
development into the linebacker is
forestalled by the fact that they're not
at the top of the pecking order right
and so their strategy is sneaky the
seriously Matt is is Matt just as
confused as I am right now I think he's
got to be
un I mean his reaction he's probably
like that was a disaster and then he
goes to the comments and they're like
this magical interview changed wow
here's here's one 600 likes I'm a person
with the disability and I thought Matt's
apology was hilarious because he didn't
pan her down to can culture and he also
raised awareness to a real website that
actually
sells you cannot be he's raising
awareness you cannot be serious right
now Matt is so that's awesome all right
right so it doesn't take much of an
imagination I would if anyone uh uh
watching has some spare time this
weekend I would genuinely love to see a
breakdown of portion talked by Jordan
vers Matt you know is anybody following
this story I don't even know what he's
talking it's a story it's not a story
it's just he's talking about a rangang
culture AP facts yeah ape facts you're
not this isn't Joe Rogan man nobody
cares to map that on to the you know the
feminist male who's so on the side of
women that you know he gets to be the
friend who can entice some poor girl
into bed when she's at her lowest point
it's almost like their own insecurity
and lack of manhood manhood probably
isn't the best word to use but it it
stunts their own Evolution well it it it
requires that a different paway to
mating success they can't dominance yeah
yeah right right exting so why did you
talk about monkeys for so why did you
decide this hold on this section is
called the two types of
orangutan a chapter swear to God that's
what it's called the and the alpha
yeah and the
cook
right this is awesome just saying so
they're moving on to a new category
called why Matt I love these chapters
reached out to Dr Peterson oh he reached
out come my podcast I'm pretty sure he
lost that title huge fan I think he's
been disgraced by the board I don't know
if they were official about
it I find you listen you and I have
never met I have I've I I'll be
truthfully honest I've never I haven't
done extensive research into everything
you've done but I find you to be a very
kind man and very well spoken and
someone stands
he is very fat women I hate fat
women he is like unnecessarily mean oh
go the trans stuff was just vile no
reason just mean for no reason he's a
sweet man a kind soul really nice let's
kill all trans people I'm a good man
with a kind soul no I'm just St that
you're gay I didn't know that I of
society today and I think that is
incredibly rare and I God whoops just
highly appreciate you oh well thank you
you I wasn't fishing for compliments but
I do appreciate the fact that they
emerged well I'm curious partly too
because you be like I think it's fair to
say your Prim I'm going to use
that funny one of his longest
uninterrupted monologues was just
glazing up he like well I want to
interrupt you now I think you're I don't
know anything about you I haven't
watched any
of I think you're cool well thank you so
much thank you no homo women I mean I'm
not certain of that but it is the case
okay and and is it almost always women
that you interact with in the crowd no
not at all it's totally total luck of
the did you do any
research like what the he hasn't
watched the special clearly because he
was referring to the crowd work in the
watch crowd work either only women he's
probably watched like a 30 second Tik
Tok like one before he went on live with
him my God
man the conservative media world is so
easy God I'm so jealous sometimes like
genuinely golly whatever happens I mean
women yell out the most for sure like
they'll Heckle the most so that will
draw more uh adamant crowd work like
that I didn't necessarily intend on
doing but overall no just is that
something that's particularly
characteristic of your shows because I
would think yeah
right kind kind of created my own
crowdwork monster in a way a friend of
mine put this in perspective for me if I
if I got popular from doing crowd work
which which was a very specific strategy
a lot of I only post my crowd work
because I don't feel like burning
through material Comics build for
minimum Year big mistake man cuz I think
your materal his material genuinely
needs more
work or yeah I just it's not funny you
know hourong show right I would feel
like a total piece of if I if I let
you pay money to come see the exact same
material you just saw for free online so
crowd workor being a very unique
circumstance that really isn't to be
duplicated at any other show that you do
cuz you're not going to meet the same
person who's been through the same
circumstance has the same story to tell
right so this is a very unique thing
that you could share and it doesn't burn
through any of your material at all so
that's why you've been making the
specials on again he really invented
comedy right well he did and then I like
that Jordan once again interrupts to
YouTube out of crowd work yeah exactly
right right cuz you can you can yeah I
haven't watched anything I don't know
what the where I am right now so
you do crowd work on YouTube just women
right you only talk to women tell me
about
that again here Ethan you're presenting
a fabricated detail as fact what was
that about that's funny I love him
everybody knows that yeah make them
permanent and you said it doesn't
interfere with the novelty of a prepared
show and so you do prepared material as
well yeah I have two full special on you
I've only seen the crowd work okay you
so he had there
you he doesn't even know what he was
cancelled for yes you didn't even watch
it that's incredible oh my God how did
you admit that wait yeah how are you
going to have a whole episode about
cancellation the whole introduction
about the guy and he doesn't even know
what he does that is crazy he's like yo
this specific moment that you got
canceled for it is crazy anyway I
haven't seen it but it yeah it be you
have no idea what happened there what a
God this is like they're almost
spitting in the audience face how little
preparation and how little red flags
there is going into this like you
Lemmings you
trites trites you're a trog you
cuck ially did that special because I
got I was getting popular for doing Red
Flag crowd work just on Tik Tok and it
got so bad to the point where I'd be in
the middle of working on material and
people would be yelling out like do red
flags or just yelling out like flipflops
or what Mom this comment imagine Jordan
being your therapist and talking about
himself the entire
time wait that's such because as a
therapist the your main job is to listen
right and he doesn't have that skill
that is interesting interesting you know
I REM me of a story interesting that
you're depressed it reminds me of a
story about orangutans if I may you ever
what do you know about lemur you know
yeah the rutain they go up in the trees
when they're big and
healthy you
know like yelling out their own red
flags without any context at all so I
was like fine I'm going to do one
special at the biggest Red Flag City
there is Miami at the Miami Improv and
then that's like the final statement
closing the chapter on my red flag Crow
work no I don't do it anymore anymore
now there's I think the special is like
50 minutes long of me just doing full
crowd work for for 50 minutes with with
the people in Miami and it was a lot of
fun I was happy to close the chapter
though this is good did Matt I'm looking
for good chapters did Matt re betray
women that's
good or psychology of offense toying
with the
Forbidden bro he he didn't his
sister what do you mean
forbidden I'm going to my sister on
stage now
taboo now that's pushing the envelope
bucko he's Brave he his own
sister on stage never seen that before
it was in June this
year you
know right in a place where everyone's
there to do that voluntarily that's part
of the game how far can we push things
and then to get all about that
and to try to cancel someone in
consequence I saw this one guy on
YouTube who's complaining about you you
know he said first of all oh may maybe
you'll recognize him he said that you
know you built your career um as an ally
of women that was basically his point
now that you've betrayed him you
betrayed them with your jokes about
domestic abuse and so he was playing
this you know I'm the friend of women
sort of game he's violating playing this
game where you pretend to care
about women they're all just liars and
frauds that's awesome it's
awesome which is that everybody's there
in a comedy club to play with
disaster and you know you're essentially
supposed to go along with that I just
don't I was listening to this and I
think to myself that can't be his real
voice like he just talks like that all
day yeah I think it does that's wild man
that's
wild all understand how the environment
isn't taken into consideration like that
is the environment is the context think
of Comedy like a store like a restaurant
front right you go in there there the
food's not for you you you can leave you
didn't have to stop in here it's such
comedy is such a niche field it's not I
would it's I know your audience true
right yeah because even when Jordan was
like you built your stage being an
advocate for women and he was like yeah
he did that I don't know if you saw
consider stand up comedy amaz how was he
a Hu like how does he square that with
being a huge Jordan Peterson fan is I
don't know a lot about him like what he
didn't say that he says I don't know
they both don't know about each
other he said he really likes him no I
know but he reached out to him no but
evidently okay first of all
that's Matt be downplaying his knowledge
no he literally said I'll be totally
honest I'm not super familiar with your
work which means he he does no
about him yeah okay fair enough Dan is
the man they literally don't know
anything about each
other by my art form I wouldn't it's not
film it's not television it's not music
it's not as globally celebrated in in
every household you know so I think I I
it just blows my mind that people can't
just let it be if it's not for you it's
not for you well I see what's happening
I think what what what he asking people
not to get
mad that but he he's not addressing the
real question it's your
audience you you for some reason
apparently garnered a lot of women in
your audience yes and then you're
pissing them off so
mhm yeah I don't think he's H I don't
think he wants to interact with that
first of all that's a hell of a way to
put it because I don't think he I think
he's trying to convince himself that
that's not true I'm trying to understand
like why he doesn't want this audience
anymore maybe because they would admit
that he's not actually funny and they
just follow him for his looks yeah maybe
and like maybe the the
a part a portion of that where um if
comedians I think first of all women
comedians already get on by men
like no no woman comedian is funny
enough or good enough that she's not
just being like a doing stick or
something and then and then I think even
further people will say oh you have a
female audience so you're not that funny
just because women like you so I need
more men to watch so I can go on Joe
Rogan show and be cool with show up a
work work harder and he did go on Joe
Rogan and talk you show up at work chill
dude that that that um that criticized
you in the manner that I just described
I found what he had to say and him for
that matter contemptible I thought it
was I ha him but this is something
social media does is bro okay I'm I'm
done he goes I saw a video he was a
piece of anyway I think he was
watching you talk about it it could have
been I think so well he I was I was
wondering that cuz you did say that he
said what did he say he said I was
trying well somebody whoever he was
watching was being the fake female
friend but but yeah you think he's
talking about me I do wait let me go
back and I don't know though because the
way they were phrasing it sounded like
whoever it was was reacting much harsher
than you did you mostly your take was
mostly that it's just a bad joke and
it's hacky yeah you know what I mean and
that it's DB to try and intentionally
piss off your fan base yeah Ethan is a
skinny Legend oh thank you that's nice
to hear is a Greek
goddess deserves a raise oh wow that I
don't know about Zach is the best in the
game that's that's so true stop dissing
the Nazis all the time wait wait wait
Jordan hold on oh chill bro chill I will
be there with my daughter ripping benzo
in the green no that's up don't
say that come on Jordan you have a lot
to live for man you them like
three let's hear this again I want to
see if there's some way to extrapolate
it is the people saying they think it
was Hank Green Oh I want to see what
Hank said oh I think I
remember okay that's funny that he he
thought Hank was a basically yeah let me
see I think Han Green's married but I
don't
remember think of Comedy like a store
for like restaurant here it's such
comedy is such a niche field it's not I
wouldn't consider standup comedy a
mainstream art form I wouldn't it's not
film it's not television it's not music
it's not as globally celebrated in in
every household you know so I think I I
it just blows my mind that people can't
just let it be if it's not for you it's
not for you well I see what's happening
I think like even this guy that helping
dude here it is well you know there's
this guy here that that uh um that
criticized you in the manner that I just
described I found what he had to say and
him for that matter contempt I thought
it was pathetic but a pathetic
contemptible this is something
social media does oh so wait it was
before this where he described it hold
on enironment is the context enironment
no shut up I just don't understand how
the environment isn't Tak can you can
you just get me the time stamp cuz I
can't do this
I do want to watch that Hank Green one
that apparently triggered you want the
time stamp of the Hank Green
thing I saw it on is that what you're
asking for or Tik Tok but I want no I
want to hear him describing the hater so
I I want to didn't Jordan say he watched
on YouTube let's find it it's somewhere
right here I'll
great you know I saw it on YouTube there
was a big cucky loser he was pretending
to care about women but I know better
men don't care about women they're just
dolls for us Superior
bigs except my grandma she can have her
way with
me anytime I let her have her
way what was that that was me doing a
barely mediocre yeah I thought it was a
sound by to I let her have her way wow
what the it doesn't sound like
you okay who's Jay fella someone says El
I'm rocking TF in my last video J fella
was uh one of the entries to one of the
music contest I forget which one the
diss track the Ryan kavan on Dis
Track it was one that you all really
liked and uh yeah they they sent a
message earlier that I assume that
they're joking saying Day Street podcast
Ruined My Life
um but now they sent another one that
said El I'm rocking Teddy fresh in my
latest in my last
video Shout Out J fell we love J fell he
he I think it got second place I want to
say oh yeah he did the F yeah so wait
this hold on let me click this let's
check it
out two days ago how the a podcast
ruined my life here we go oh he's
older than I expected this is it now
remember we talked with him or in some
way we knew that he was an older guy
he's he's got a he's like a dad with
family oh man that's sick I love that I
love that this is the story dad's rise
up the H3 podcast what's he do for a
living I wonder
Don I mean shattered my dreams every
single hope and dream I've ever had
sh I'm I'm going to um I'm going to
screen this and then we can watch it on
Monday but shout out Jay fella oh
there's one guy on YouTube who
complaining about you you
know oh I want to thank uh there's all
kinds of there's a bunch all right let
me finish this I'll read them and then
we'll may maybe you'll recognize
him he said that you know you built your
career um as an ally of women that was
basically his point oh definitely Hank
Green yeah that's that's what he said
yeah there you go yeah Daddy betrayed
him you betrayed them with your jokes
about domestic abuse and so he was
playing this you know I'm the friend of
women sort of game so hold on now I got
to now we got to watch that to see his
characterization is yeah Fair
yeah as we look for that I want to say
Abby
Bello thank you for the Dono Laura
Morini thank you so much for the Dono
she said hi I'm a speech therapist and I
found out today that one of my high
school students is family whoa can't
wait to use parts of the show in therapy
and connect with him more I said I'd
Super Chat as proof I'm a fan L peace
and
love oh she means watches the podcast
not that she is actually family right
mhm oh that's what they mean I
thought I thought it was like yo you
guys are okay family I don't know why I
missed that family Anastasia thank you
so much for the gifted she said flu and
covid vaccines are intramuscular the
sound could have been from the safety of
the needle
retracting a little bit of air is not
going to kill you also nurses are not
just nurses we work very hard okay
apologies yeah we love you we love you
we love you you're very special very
special are we sure that it was a
hankering clip by the way and not just a
tweet cuz I do have the Tweet which says
essentially the same thing yeah that's
probably it then okay no I I think it
was in the video he said it was YouTube
but he was short yeah he's wrong penzo
addict and Monica said hey guys shouted
out shout me out for my birthday during
the subathon so thank you my friend
Bella's birthday is this month I hope
you all will tell her happy birthday too
love you guys so much uh Happy Birthday
to B Ethan is hot we all agree stop
[Applause]
stop hello everyone looking beautiful
today except Ethan still has his rash I
do I feel like it's getting better
slowly but yeah it's not really going
anywhere does look better today um
Jasper kid kicks ass Dan check out the
dark tide
soundtrack oh that that that was the
soundtrack oh there you go wound up
putting it into my top five so yes so
don um you're welcome thank you to
passenger shaming for five gifted and
Emily for five gifted we love you you're
very special all right here's Hank's
Tweet now there was a video I thought it
was like a Twitter video but this is
essentially what he says a comedian
ruining his relationship with a large
portion wait maybe I'm M I'm having a
fake memory maybe it was just a tweet yo
really Ethan
yo okay well in the video he said he saw
a video right so that made may have just
implanted that thought into your head
that it was a video yep anyway he said a
comedian ruining his relationship with a
large portion of his fan base because he
wanted to be like all the other boring
ass Netflix specials you can't tell a
joke anymore crowd is actually
depressing that's a great that's a great
observation to be honest so true is this
what he was talking about maybe there
was a video somewhere too but I'm having
a hard time finding it I really think he
the sentiment essentially there you
think so we said that we were like you
make yourself an ally to women Jordan's
a secret fan and Jordan Jordan he might
hate watch hates you you think he hate
watches I know I know we're bitter
Rivals bu Ethan the boys over there the
crew hold on abuse and so he was playing
this you know I'm the friend of women
sort of game but he's violating that
contract too is that everybody's there
in a comedy club Play With Disaster and
and you know you're essentially supposed
to go along with that yeah I just don't
I wish you would have said my name that
would have been the best this clown this
Israel clown this is clown Ethan Klein
pretending to like women what a joke my
grandmother's pubes wow can you blame me
for not liking women my grandmother had
her way with me clown
comedian all right uh J fell says it
won't get claimed it's a spoof okay all
right I'm take a look at we'll check it
out on Monday yeah weac says my daughter
was born around the same time as Bruce
and I can remember binging Isley pod
while she slept in my arms she gotten so
big it goes by quick love you guys yeah
it does go by quick and I'll tell you
what the time when they're
newborn especially the first one cuz
there's nothing else to do that time
when they're newborn and you have like
tons of free time to just sit there and
veg out is is a wonderful time it's a
nice time I'll never forget that factor
every episode
yeah thank you baby but now once you
have already have a kid then the fun is
the fun is over once you already have a
kid because you got to take care of that
other
little
uh whirl uh hurricane or teapot or that
little Tempest in a
teapot all right well that's about it eh
that's about it all right so
listen
friends and uh uh enemies
alike oh did you want to watch the video
not up that we blew earlier oh
yeah before good call yeah yeah I do
want to watch that here
uh where are
you it' be really funny if it was the
audio was on Twitter too hello
every year M okay so let me say goodbye
and then we we can play him off with
that we can play it off with that okay
so guys thank you so much we love you
thanks for watching another week of
shows we're coming up on the live show
it's coming up fast man it's crazy it's
like two weeks away now right yes indeed
a little over two but yeah it's very
soon um anyway thank you guys for your
continued support we love you all so
much and thank you to our members and
everybody for watching and we'll be back
next week for another fantastic week of
shows looking forward to it and I'll see
you guys then than you everybody oh my
God hello every year multiple podcast
producers miss out on lunch and snacks
because they were too distracted to
place their
order every year without you even
realizing it a podcast producer goes
hungry because they failed to put their
order in for some overpriced artisanal
salad or unnecessarily sugary Boba drink
these producers slip through the cracks
of company card expensed meals look at
this face gaze upon it what do you see
sadness me
too but for just one pack of H3 podcast
trading cards you yourself can help feed
a
camera hey can I have this
D put it
back don't let this poor camera Miss
lunch during these final 24 hours
purchase a pack of H3 trading cards and
we might just let this podcast producer
have a $25 avocado infused Jett aroan
cleansing smoothie do it for Cameron do
it for podcast producers
everywhere
sadness me
too